Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Durch glaube im Bundestag gab es einen sehr bedauerlichen Fall von did you first.
Leider können wir ja Christian Lindner mal in diese Sendung holen wie sich das mit dem Bedenken second so anfühlt wir haben ja jetzt eine Nummer.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 281 die
erste Sendung im Jahre 2019 vom 6. Januar wir sind also heute eure zwei heiligen Könige die euch die Kunde der letzt Politik näher
bring möchten und was sonst noch so wichtig war.
Was haben wir mitgebracht Huxleys & dogs brachten die zwei heiligen aus dem Abendland.
Die zwei heiligen aus dem Ausland für Unterhaltung und Information sorgen wollen denn das ist unser Auftrag stimmt.
Ja genau das ist unser das so sehen wir das sehen wir das und natürlich Radfahrt sollen wir sollen wir beginnt im.
Wir können gleich einsteigen in das Bundes doch C-Promi dogs.
Dass das Runde bunte das bunte Promi boxing es ist ein Fest wie soll ich sagen also es begann.
Diese Woche am Donnerstag wo ich so I dringende Rückrufbitten erhielt von verschiedenen Betroffenen.
Die hier plötzlich festgestellt hatten das persönliche Daten von Ihnen im Internet kursieren und es stellte sich dann raus dass.
Seit dem 1. Dezember ein bestimmter Twitter-Account eine Art Adventskalender gestaltet hat und dann jeden Tag neue.
Daten von unterschiedlichen Personen und Personengruppen.
Online gestellt hat dabei war es eine Mischung aus teilweise alten teilweise neuen Daten.
Und so eine relativ erstaunlich akribisch zusammengetragene Datensammlungen hauptsächlich.
Sowas wie Telefonnummern und E-Mail Adressen von allen möglichen wo liegt Politikern außer der außer Politik an der AFD.
Aber auch mehrere prominente.
Und Youtuber vor allem die da irgendwie so betroffen waren und das sah erstmal relativ.
Unschön aus für alle Betroffenen weil man sich natürlich fragen muss Wo kommen solche Datenmengen her denn vereinzelt von vereinzelten Personen,
waren da auch sowas die Screenshots von Twitter-Nachrichten persönliche Fotos scannen des Personalausweis Reisepass Impfpass verschiedene,
irgendwie erstmal scheinbar wahllos zusammengeklappte,
Briefe Verträge 30 Bewerbung Mietvertrag Mietvertrag Kündigung irgendwie so so
teilweise vereinzelt teilweise auch dann mal so ein ganzes E-Mail-Postfach oder so ein Facebook Adressbuch befand sich eben zu eins zu einzelnen Personen dabei alles sehr sehr
sehr sehr ordentlich zusammengetragen aber scheinbar.
Auch so ein bisschen wahllos was natürlich erstmal zu Spekulationen anregt erstens natürlich woher.
Hat die Person oder haben die Personen diese ganzen Daten und haben Sie noch mehr oder veröffentlichen Sie alles wenn Sie alles veröffentlichen warum haben sie dann nur dass wenn noch nicht alles ist,
heißt dass sie wollen unter Umständen drohen es war auf jeden Fall erstmal eine relativ erschreckende Datensammlung die sich da offenbar.
Und ich würde dann an erster Stelle gerne einmal ein paar Begriffe hier trennen weil ja sofort vom größten Hacker Angriff der Bundesrepublik Deutschland und so weiter die Rede war.
Hacking ist wenn jemand einen ein IT system in einen Zustand versetzt.
Indem es.
Eigentlich nicht sein sollte das heißt meine Zeit verletzt die Vertraulichkeit der dort gespeicherten Daten man verletzt die Integrität des Systemes installiert also z.b. und eine Software darauf oder verändert Daten.
Oder man verletzt die Verfügbarkeit des Systemes löscht also Daten oder schaltet das System aus hier habe auf jeden Fall eine relativ ausführliche Vertraulichkeit Verletzung
die Frage ist aber ob diese Vertraulichkeit Verletzungen wirklich auf den System aller dieser Person die da drin sind stattgefunden hat
oder aber nur bei einem relativ kleinen Teil der dort gelisteten Personen und ich denke beim zweiten Blick offenbart sich sehr klar hier sind
gehackt wurden hier die wenigsten Personen die meisten Personen wurden gedoxt was auch so ein Begriff ist doxing.
Im Prinzip der die Duc glaube ich von Dokumente oder.
Ja ja dass man halt einfach die dummen so viel Dokumente so viel Information über informer bestimmte Personen einfach öffentlich
liegt mir das Lied jetzt das hacking nicht aus als hätte halt durchaus sein können dass man eben an diese Informationen p-hacking rankommt so und sie dann doxxed also
muss er mir das veröffentlichen und nicht so sehr das wie man da rankommt aber es macht halt jetzt nicht so den Eindruck als ob es hier einen Hack
geben habe wo alle diese Informationen rausgefallen sind die dann vielleicht auch in einer einheitlichen Datendarstellung vorliegen soll es mir so ein Sammelsurium man könnte auch sagen hier wurde intensiv
recherchierte teilweise macht es eben den Eindruck dass Account übernommen wurden und darüber diese Informationen kamen
weiß man nicht also in dem Moment wo es so Twitter DM's und so was sind liegt es natürlich nahe viele Informationen scheinen auch aus E-Mail Postfächern gekommen zu sein das könnte bedeuten dass halt hier entsprechende übernahmen von E-Mail-Accounts stattgefunden haben
oder eben Passwörter aus anderen Quellen zur Anwendung kamen das lässt sich halt so glaube ich ohne weiteres nicht sagen.
Wenn wir mal nur um die Begriffe klar zu halten wenn jetzt jemand mich meinen Account übernimmt und dort das Adressbuch sieht und dann
da drin die Telefonnummer von Tim findet und die Telefonnummer von Tim veröffentlicht dann bin ich quasi das hacking Opfer und Tim wurde aber nicht gehackt sondern in dem Fall dann halt gedoxxt,
ernst weil seine persönlichen Daten irgendwie veröffentlicht wurden du hast gerade schon gesagt wir sehen natürlich auch ein Muster
bei denen wo offenbaren unerlaubter Zugriff auf tatsächliche Dokumente stattgefunden hat und diese Dokumente auch gelegt bzw veröffentlicht wurden da hast du in der Regel so was wie,
private Daten also man sieht oft Scan des Personalausweises man sieht oft Screenshots z.b. von Twitter DM man sieht einzeln interessante Daten sowas wie was dass ich,
Mietvertrag Mietvertrag Kündigung Bewerbung oder sowas man sieht auch mal so einen kompletten Dump eines web.de Postfach.
Und das deutet ein bisschen darauf hin dass da bestimmte Suchbegriffe zur Anwendung gekommen sind ne also es könnte sein dass der Angreifer oder die Angreiferin die Daten vollständig hat,
vielleicht aber auch nur in so einer Sammler Manier überall mal rein gegangen ist weil das ganze Ding hat auf jeden Fall so die.
Man sieht dass da jemand sehr sehr sehr akribisch gesammelt und sortiert hat ja und.
Gleichzeitig findet sich zumindest bis jetzt ich habe mir halt auch nicht alles Material angeschaut.
Kein großer Skandal dadrin es geht glaube ich eher um die Verletzungen Bloßstellung der Menschen und.
Für die Anzahl der der Leute die da gehackt von dir natürlich absolut immer noch hoch ist nur relativ im.
In der Alkane an der Anzahl der Betroffenen daneben gering ist hier verhältnismäßig wenig veröffentlicht.
Na ja wer war betroffen alle im Bundestag vertretenen Parteien außer der AFD.
Eine Reihe liberaler Satiriker wie jetzt irgendwie Jan Böhmermann Nico semsrott Oliver Welke,
Musiker wie KIZ Marteria Casper,
Youtuber wie Rayk anders dann sind diese Richtung funkner Jäger und Sammler Tarik tesfu dann auch irgendwie,
Fabian Siegismund kenne ich nicht aber der wurde auch gehackt aber seine Daten wurden aus Visp
nicht veröffentlicht wo wo wo sich irgendwie eine eine klare.
Einerseits sind die Ziele scheinbar wahllos ausgewählt andererseits lässt sich eine klare Linie da erkennen wer eben.
Nicht ausgewählt wurde er hat nämlich sagen wir mal im weitesten Sinne irgendwelche vielleicht dann doch nicht ganz so liberal agierenden Trolle Rayk anders und Funk haben sich ja seit ihrer Doku,
lösch dich wo sie so ein bisschen YouTube.
Schwachmaten mal so ein bisschen hinterher recherchiert haben durchaus einige Feinde gemacht und bei Rayk anders haben sie auch besonders übel zugeschlagen.
Teilweise.
War aber auch einige dabei die jetzt nicht unbedingt so jetzt an der vordersten Front der Guard sie Aufklärung dabei.
Bin ich absolut absolut richtig und da da da da da von da hin dort ja auf die Spur ich fand am Anfang auffällig.
Der Begriff doxing doxing oder oder ohne den denen der oder die Angreiferin darauf verwendet.
Das kommt auch so nach so einer anderen Szene ja das ist irgendwie so doxing das machen halt ich meine keine Ahnung was soll das ja also doxing ist ja im Prinzip dieses irgendwie Menschen einschüchtern.
Und ihn unangenehmes bereiten wie z.b. hier Martin Schulz dessen privates handy halt dann da auf einmal klingelt weil einer anruft ne oder Christian Lindner den wir gleich noch live in die Sendung schalten es einfach nervig,
so das nervig für die Leute wenn es darum wenn es dann um hochkarätiger richiede geht wie jetzt irgendwie Angela Merkel oder so dann werden diese Daten irgendwann auch zugegebenermaßen brisant.
Insbesondere Handynummern die ja über ss7 auch ein location tracking ermöglichen,
werden dann natürlich irgendwann problematisch jetzt stellt sich aber raus dieser Typ oder dieser ich gehe jetzt mal davon aus dass ein Typ ist weil irgendwie.
Das halt auf gewisse charakterliche Unzulänglichkeiten Hindu heute die man bei Frauen nicht so oft findet wie bei Männern.
Der ist in der YouTube Szene gar nicht so unbekannt mehr man sah auch hat ja auch irgendwie dieses YouTube Produktionsunternehmen dann da gedoxxt wo man auch Märkte ok der hat sich offenbar irgendwie der beschäftigt sich mit diesem YouTube Universum.
Und hatte auch am schon vor Jahren irgendwie Accounts übernommen von irgendwelchen Youtubern,
und Ideen dann in der Regel zurückgegeben ja also irgend so ein bisschen.
Wie soll man das sagen so ein bisschen manisch und wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen oder sehr offensichtlich sehr sehr geltungsbedürftig ja weil er.
Weil er eben auch im Prinzip sehr darauf bedacht war auf sich aufmerksam zu machen Mann stellte sich jetzt diese arme Seele vor die da ihren wieder ihren Adventskalender macht mit einem übrigens sehr schön von
heise-online ich glaube von Fabian scherschel reduziert mit einem
übernommenen Twitter-Account der hat nämlich also der Twitter-Account wurde im Februar 2015 kreiert.
Und hatte irgendwie 18.000 follow-up und.
Der hatte einmal 2703 die wurden aber alle im Juni 2017 gelöscht diese Information im es auch nicht nur von Fabian scherschel sondern auch von,
lukahammer zusammengetragen schön recherchiert und stellt sich raus der hat wohl davor auch ein Youtuber gehört
die mir in dem Fall den Account wohl nicht zurückgegeben hat andere berichten dass Ihr Account teilweise weggenommen wurden und sie die dann wieder bekommen haben so ein bisschen für quasi dagegen einen Bekanntmachung dass sie übernommen wurden
ja also so ein bisschen bisschen komisch dieser YouTube Account er dieser Twitter-Account gehörte wohl einem Youtuber namens dezztroyz.
DHL und Yannick Kromer mit bürgerlichem Namen heißt und irgendwie in Richtung 200000 Follower mit Minecraft.
Spieler trolling auf YouTube erlangt hat ja also so das scheint so diese Szene zu sein man merkt wahrscheinlich dass ich da nicht ganz wirr bin.
Was die einzelnen.
Charaktere angeht ich habe halt noch nicht mal Zeit wirklich Computer zu spielen geschweige denn Zeit anderen dabei zuzuschauen aber aus dieser Szene kommt das.
Und die sind diesen Twitter-Account den hat er wohl dem armen dezztroyz nicht zurückgegeben sondern behalten einfach mal alle Cheats gelöschten Account umbenannt und hatte dann halt diese 18/19 1000 Follower dieser dieser Account hatte
und hat dann damit wirklich seit 1. Dezember jeden Tag eben, wenn ich hier gelegt habe und guck mal wie ich hier gelegt habe und obwohl er kommt so viele Follower hatte ist das irgendwie keinem aufgefallen ich komme
also ich kann mir das auch nur irgendwie.
Noch nicht so ganz erklären ich schätze das halt offenbar viele Leute diese Nachrichten bekommen haben aber nicht.
Hier bin ich ernst genommen haben da stand jetzt auch nicht dran hier der große die Grünen liegt sondern irgendwie sowas wie
Adventskalender Türchen 1 Doppelpunkt die Grünen oder so ja und ich kann mir vorstellen dass das jetzt für viele Leute die diesen Account aus Gründen folgten die sie ja gar nicht kannten.
Das hat er jetzt viele zum Klicken motiviert hat sondern das Hirn einfach ihr besorgen scroll mal weiter.
Neuer Weg.
Adventskalender habe ich selber schon gegessen heute gib mal Minecraft Video oder so ne,
und es ist nicht tragisch dass das der dass der Typ der seine Recherchearbeit die auf jeden Fall über Jahre geht ja also man sieht auch einige Daten sind durchaus älter und man hört auch von einigen.
Dass sie sagen die Daten wurden auch vorher schon veröffentlicht ja also da wollte jetzt einfach mal jemand was weiß ich sein Lebenswerk da als Weihnachtskalender als Adventskalender präsentieren und stell dir vor es ist ist es ist Adventskalender und keiner guckt hin
das war irgendwie so dass das Drama dieses Abend dieser am Personen und.
Dann hat er offenbar irgendwann dann noch mal den Account von einem Herrn Unger übernommen der Herr unge der betreibt auch einfach nicht das Falsche wissen.
Wer betreibt auch einen einen YouTube-Kanal wo man ihn beim Nintendo Spiel zugucken kann.
Wie schnell das auch beim beim beim Entwickeln von Verschwörungstheorien.
Der Sound Verschwörungstheoretiker.
Er ist mir so ein Hobby Verschwörungstheoretiker der irgendwie so
von Zeit zu Zeit mal den ein oder anderen Looney auf dem Leim geht und dann und wir auch mal einen schlechten Tag hat und dann irgendwie durch Nebelschwaden läuft und irgendwie erzählt das wäre erst keiner kein Nebel sein das ist ja alles Gift.
Und so und Milch ist sie.
Du hast den irgendwann schon mal angesprochen da kannte ich den auch nicht.
Habe ich den schon mal angesprochen weiß ich gar nicht.
Irgendwann vor vor langer Zeit im Logbuch glaube ich hast du ihm okay.
Also der der der der hat schon der hat schon erhöhten koptisch Fakt.
Okay ich kenne nicht der wo auf jeden Fall hat er seinen Account nicht unter Kontrolle und,
dann dann wurde dort halt über dessen Account irgendwie auch getwitterte schaut mal hier Leute was ich tolles habe ja.
Dazu übrigens ganz interessant ich habe das ist jetzt die Welle Ping Information aber wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe,
der Herr sehr wohl seinen Twitter-Account mit Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung abgesichert.
Allerdings also es ist jetzt zumindest die Behauptung die im Raum steht das,
kann ich natürlich nicht mit finaler Sicherheit sagen aber die Behauptung im Raum steht ist dass er quasi den dann wiederum über einen GMail-Account also überleg E-Mail E-Mail-Adresse quasi das war sozusagen die hinterlegte E-Mail-Adresse
und das dann aber dieser GMail-Account von ihm hops genommen wurde und deiner Person Twitter wiederum dazu gebracht hat Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung für diesen
count auszuschalten über diesen GMail-Account.
Das dass die Behauptung die im Raum steht auf jeden Fall noch mal interessant das zu verfolgen weil wenn das stimmt dann.
Das halt die Diskussion noch mal ein bisschen weiter weil geht ja gar nicht ne.
Da würde ich wirklich gerne gleich am Ende noch mal ein bisschen drauf kommen mit dem mit dem technischen Vorgehen wir wissen ja bisher relativ wenig und es ich bin da vorsichtig mit der mit der Spekulation aber
was ich glaube ich festhalten lässt ist diese diese ganze zwei faktorisiere rei.
Und diese ganzen authentifizierungsmöglichkeiten die von den unterschiedlichen Diensten angeboten werden die sind ja teilweise komplementär,
ja und wir erinnern uns z.b. vor Jahren gab es so schöne Fälle wo wie war das denn bei Account a,
haben sie dir das Ende deiner Kreditkartennummer gezeigt und haben gesagt du sollst den Anfang eingeben und bei Anbieter B,
haben sie den Anfang gezeigt haben gesagt du sollst das Ende angeben ja so dass du quasi wenn du Accounts bei beiden hattest mussten die Angreifer nur einmal den einen angucken und einmal den anderen und der eine hat quasi die Antwort für den anderen geliefert ja,
solche solche Dinge passieren regelmäßig und da entstehen halt teilweise sehr.
Ein eleganter Gebilde er ähnlich wie hier Donald Trump der sein,
Twitter-Konto halt an die E-Mail-Adresse Donald Trump at gmail.com gebunden hatte und als dann
alt und Twitter hat er dann quasi gesagt Eier okay wir haben die die Daten zur Wiederherstellung deines Accounts an die Sternchen Sternchen Sternchen Sternchen Sternchen Sternchen Sternchen Sternchen Sternchen
gmail.com geschickt wodurch dann natürlich für jeden Dänemark mitdenkt klar ist dass es eine e-mail Adresse bei GMail gibt die auf diesem Namen lautet und,
da kann man wenn man da beständig sich hinter hängt sehr viele Informationen sammeln dafür gibt es schöne Tools die einem auch dabei helfen solche Informationen über Menschen zu sammeln.
Und wenn man dann da bestimmte Konstellationen von Möglichkeiten sieht vielleicht Accounts zurückzusetzen oder von der einen Rücksetzung Informationen zu bekommen für die andere und dann irgendwann vielleicht,
Passwort Dahms rum suchen kann ja und ihr wie versteht a-ok hier ist diese E-Mail-Adresse dann gucken wir doch mal ob diese E-Mail-Adresse,
sich z.b. vor 5 Jahren oder was in irgendeinem,
Dropbox E-Mail Account und Passwort liegt befunden hat dann gucken wir mal ob vielleicht dieses Passwort immer noch bei dieser E-Mail-Adresse gesetzt wird uns so man sieht wie weit da jemand kommen kann der sowas,
in Ruhe und systematischen macht und das ist eigentlich das was ich hier am Mais am am beunruhigenden finde dass es einen Menschen.
Der dafür die Zeit.
Nicht nur hatte sollen sie sich auch genommen hat und man sieht das ja der beachtliche Erfolge hatte und die haben bisher keine Hinweise darauf dass er.
Technisch besonders.
Besonders herausragend vorgegangen ist ja kann sein dass ich das noch findet bisher sieht es aber eher so aus als hätte er halt eine Reihe an
Recherchearbeiten geleistet und ebenso in der so in der Lage gewesen offen bei den ein oder anderen privaten Account zu übernehmen gerne vielleicht auch mal
durch interessante Bilder aus Wiederherstellungs Möglichkeiten und so aber es sieht sieht jetzt erstmal nicht danach aus dass hier ein Hacker mit,
besonderen technischen Fähigkeiten am Werke war womit besonderen technischen Fähigkeiten will ich dann so etwas in meinen sie hat
Kenntnis von besonderen Sicherheitslücken von denen niemand anderes wusste hat bestimmte,
gezielt bestimmte Systeme infiziert nach allem was ich bisher gesehen habe sieht es ehrlich gesagt danach aus dass der.
Gänzlich ohne Chartsoftware ausgekommen ist
kann sein ich habe noch nicht alles gesehen kann sein dass ich das noch ändert aber es sieht ehrlich gesagt nach jemandem aus der einfach eine sehr schöne sehr schönen Hang zu akribischen Recherche hat.
Und der ein Händchen dafür hat schlecht gesichert Accounts übernehmen mal schauen ob sich das noch ändern.
Ja oder erhängt sich meine verfolgst du ja quasi gerade Einzeltäter Theorie ich würde das jetzt auch nicht unbedingt ausschließen dass es sich hier nicht auch oben so eine
Chat Runde Handels ja wo die Informationen aus mehreren Quellen von mehreren Personen zusammengetragen wurden und dieses und einer davon
entweder als kollektiver Beschluss oder als Einzelmaßnahme jetzt der Meinung war das alles mal in die in die Welt zu legen Fiskars Ente.
Da bin ich sogar da bin ich sogar ganz bei dir ganz kurz ich bin in den ich bin ich habe ja mehr oder weniger den gesamten Freitag dann mit mit Medienberichterstattung Betreuung verbracht,
ich habe immer gesagt ich gehe von Angreifern aus es gibt aber jetzt inzwischen einen.
Youtuber namens Thomas Nitsch der.
Sag ihr wisst auch schon mal dieser Person zum Opfer gefallen hat mit dieser Person einen Austausch gehabt chattet wohl regelmäßig und sagt er ist sich sicher das war mit Sicherheit ein.
Angreifer.
Und der hat offen beim Erkenntnisse über diese Person als ich ich würde aber sagen es kann sehr gut sein dass hier unter Umständen unterschiedliche Quellen auch zusammengetragen wurden.
Also nicht alles was wir da finden muss unbedingt auch von dieser einen Person erbeutet worden sein zumindest diese Veröffentlichung aber scheint auf eine Person zurückzugehen.
Was hat will ich jetzt die Öffentlichkeit nicht davon abgehalten hat zahlreiche Erklärungsversuche heranzuziehen was denn jetzt hier stattgefunden haben kann und was denn deswegen zu tun wäre.
Ja das natürlich sowieso und ich meine dass ich mich wird gerne noch ganz kurz auf Aufladenummer eben über sowas was wir über den Täter oder die Täterin wissen eingehen,
der hat in meinen Augen eine ganze Reihe Fehler gemacht die.
Die vermeidbar gewesen werden Nerven gibt es relativ viel von sich preis z.b. irgendwie Ansichten über bestimmte Youtuber bei diesem
LeFloid Community Teamspeak also das LeFloid ist auch ein Youtuber der hat offenbar ein einen Community Teamspeak wo Leute,
also Teamspeak ist ja so ein javi Mumble eigentlich ne also so ein man kann da so ein Audio Chat genau.
Und da verrät er dann in diesem lied schreibt er ihn wieder sehr Ärger hatte mit einem der Admin und der hätte ihn öfter geblockt,
das ist nicht klug zu in so ein Lied mit reinzuschreiben ja das ist wirklich nicht klug so,
der hat in den in den Export dieser Daten also wenn er da irgendwie bei Leuten die es Facebook Adressbuch exportiert hat oder so dann standen unten noch die timestamps drin also wann dieser Zugriff erfolgt ist
das heißt es sitzt jetzt irgendwo jemand in irgendeinem Logfile bei facebook steht.
Wann sich jemand unter diesem Account eingeloggt hat und diesen Export gemacht hat,
gehört sich nicht so was da drin zu lassen er macht viele wertende Aussagen über Betroffenen über diesen Siegesmund über das Produktionsunternehmen.
Und für dann auch noch,
ausführliche Chats mit den Betroffenen einer davon eben dieser Thomas nimm jetzt gibt irgendwie schon in der Zeitung Interviews darüber er sagt ja soundso ich kann schon mal verraten wie der Vorname nicht ist und so.
Außerdem berichten diese Youtuber die Betroffenen YouTube
dass die Person irgendwie so ein Geltungsdrang hat ja so verlangt hat ihm die so ja du musst das aber du musst twittern dass du von mir gehackt wurdest dann gebe ich dir den Account zurück oder so ja.
Klingt nach fünfzehnjährig und Vene.
Sehr dass du immer so bleiben kannst du ich habe schon auch erwachsene Menschen gesehen die sich wie Kinder aufführen.
Jaja soso mental 15 jährig.
Es klingt auf jeden Fall einfach nicht also wenn die Person am Ende erwischt wird dann.
Weil sie
zu hohen Geltungsdrang hatte weil sie zu viel mit Leuten gequatscht hat weil sie Wert darauf gelegt hat irgendwie auch attribuiert zu werden benannt zu werden
und das da glaube ich dabei die Person nicht so ganz gut beraten andererseits stelle ich mir echt gerade so eine sind deprimierten.
Doxa vor der in Gdingen.
Irgendwie da so viel Arbeit in diese Datensammlung gesteckt hat er oder eine Gruppe die so viel Arbeit in diese Datensammlung gesteckt hat und dann evtl kompletten Weihnachten über im Prinzip mit mittig,
Ignoranz bestraft wird und irgendwie nur nur ihre 5 Minuten haben möchte dass ich der Gott der Orbiter hier.
Diese Leute alle gesammelt habe guck mal was ich gemacht habe werdet ihr alle Infos über let's play videos auf youtube guckt habe ich hier Telefonnummern gesammelt und und Account übernommen.
Und und dann plötzlich so wirklich echt viel viel viel zu spät der ganze Scheiße schon vorbei
bricht halt dann irgendwie die internationale Presse über dich herein und du bist zweimal irgendwie so der der meistgesuchte Hacker ist wird von der von der schlimmsten,
flip the hacking Angriff überhaupt geredet du wirst schon mit denen du wirst schon als von den Russen fremdgesteuert von der von den Kalk Kriegern bezeichnet so.
Spätestens dann fällt dir auf dass das OpSec echt.
Aber das mal lieber.
Vorher gemacht werden muss.
Dein und tas Vortrag auf dem Kongress vorher Gesicht hättest befunden Aktivitäten gestartet hast.
Ich esse ich bin gespannt.
Bin ganz ehrlich also ich sehe da sehr viele Nachlässigkeiten und bin mal gespannt ob wir in Deutschland die Kapazitäten haben die auch alle systematisch auszuwerten.
Im Moment sitze erstmal nicht davor danach aus ja also wir haben die am schwersten betroffenen Personen dieses dieses Datenlecks die haben bisher noch nicht mal was vom BSI gehört irgendwelche Personen
Informationen zu dem Angreifer haben erzähl die erzählen großspurig in der Süddeutschen Zeitung dass sie bisher von niemandem Kontakt,
wurden und darüber selber verwundert sind also bisher,
soll ich was sind die deutschen Sicherheitsbehörden da nicht unbedingt auf von der besten Seite zu sehen sehr schön übrigens auch hier Arne jetzt hätte ich schon alle semsrott gesagt Arne,
wie heißt der denn.
Müssen alle meinst du denn jetzt achso.
Einen schönen Baum der der Vorsitzende des Dreigestirn.
Köln Köln-Bonn BSE tschuldigung des WSE der.
Danieli gefragt wurde am Freitag soll ja sagen Sie mal da ist ja so ein riesiger lag das läuft ja alles schon seit Dezember,
wussten Sie denn da nicht von und ihr seid erst so ja klar wussten wir davon gar keine Frage seit Anfang Dezember wissen wir davon ja und dann wird nachdem er erkennt uns erklären Sie uns doch mal bitte warum sie es gemacht haben.
Pfandfrage Fangfrage Fangfrage wer muss für mich dann mussten sie direkt erklärt ja wir wussten von Einzelfällen aber nicht von dem gesamten Ausmaß und,
ich bin tatsächlich auch überrascht ich habe ehrlich gesagt so am Freitag Nachmittag dann gedacht zu naja ok.
Jetzt werden diese Daten ja alle mal weg sein Außennetz,
und da muss man aber jetzt sagen da hat unsere Angreifer äußerst akribisch gearbeitet also man sieht ja echt so einen Hang zu Akribie der jeden als jede einzelne Daten die der da veröffentlicht hat auf
Mirrors gelegt auf viele verschiedene verschiedenen pace Binz und
und megaupload und und hier noch andere und hier noch ein Büro und hier noch einen Rock der muss allein tagelang damit beschäftigt gewesen sein diese Daten an den unterschiedlichen Stellen hochzuladen.
Und,
ja ich habe gerade zu sendungsformat eitung noch mal geschaut ob den jetzt alles weg ist so und es mitnichten so also da fragt man sich auch was die da jetzt eigentlich.
Gerade machen in ihrem fiber.
Sicherheitsrat oder in ihrem BSI oder wer auch immer sich da jetzt gerade für verantwortlich für Horst Seehofer ist es ja nicht der ist ja nur in Minister.
Er muss ein bisschen Verständnis haben im Dezember haben die sich wahrscheinlich alle auf dem Kongress.
Also das ist das ist ja wie soll ich das abschließend bewerten ich bin also diese Person hatte jetzt.
Keine herausragenden Fähigkeiten außer echt mal offen
Engelsgeduld und einer Akribie diesen ganzen Kram zusammen zu sammeln du musst am Ende wahrscheinlich nur ein Adressbuch von
einem Mitarbeiter einer Bundestagsabgeordneten unter deine Kontrolle bringen um am Ende sehr sehr viele
E-Mail Adressen und Telefonnummern aus den unterschiedlichen Fraktionen zu haben ich bin mir relativ sicher dass es da am Ende eine
einfache Erklärung gibt auch Journalistinnen und Journalisten sind ja hier unter den Zielen gewesen auch die haben mitunter natürlich relativ viel,
relativ viele Personen in ihren Adressbüchern du hast natürlich auch so eine du hast ja von jeder Partei oder Fraktion im Bundestag ja auch eine Übersicht wer das ist,
ja dann kannst du anfangen zu suchen die Datenqualität ist.
Unter aber auch schwankend irgendwie von Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer ist irgendwie eine E-Mail-Adresse angegeben die relativ eindeutig nicht ihre ist ja also das ist eher so ein sogenannter funktionsaccount wo also.
Der offenbar zum zum Versand von,
Mitglieder Briefen an die CDU verwendet wird oder so was für ein bisschen darauf hindeutet dass die Daten vielleicht auch Teil automatisiert eben aus aus verschiedenen liegst zusammengekratzt wurden.
Aber andererseits das ist natürlich auch das erschreckend.
Wenn hier ein Einzeltäter dann kleines Grüppchen mit Fleiß und Spucke hier solche Daten zusammen sucht und eben auch mehrere Einzelpersonen.
Übernehmen kann das sollte schon wirklich jetzt mal ein.
Einen Weckruf sein und zwar gar nicht unbedingt an die.
An die IT des Bundes wo das BSI ja auch sehr sehr stolz sagt unsere Systeme sind nicht betroffen das immer das erste was ist BSE sagt ne wenn wir aber bei den vergangenen Hacks des Bundestages und so auch immer gesehen
nananananana bei uns ist alles sicher bei uns ist alles sicher ja aber deine deine Schutzbefohlenen rennen eben.
Mit irgendwelchen Twitter-Account durch die Gegend mit irgendwelchen Web.de Account mit irgendwelchen Facebook-Account,
haben da keine Ahnung was sie da tun ne verwenden im Zweifelsfall überall,
die gleichen Passwörter und so weiter und so fort man kann die Frage stellen die wurde auch gestellt hat das BSI denn wegen solch gegen solche Datenlecks kein monitoring ja und da bin ich.
Da bin ich jetzt mal so ein bisschen vorsichtig also.
Ja die hätten das früher merken müssen ja die hätten es auch früher merken müssen als ich einzelne Individuen bei denen.
Gemeldet haben die ja offenbar schon im Dezember gemerkt haben dass mit ihren Accounts irgendwas nicht stimmt
aber dieser Twitter-Account hat halt irgendwie auf eine Weise diese Sachen getwittert wo ich mir vorstellen kann das halt kein Suchbegriff und kein monitoring anschlägt irgendwie Adventskalender die Grünen da
der kommt nicht dogs drin vor der kommt nicht liegt drin vor da kommt keine Telefonnummern drin vor dann geht es zu diesem payspin Seiten,
die in der Regel passwortgeschützt waren das Passwort war immer nur sowas wie 123,
aber das reicht natürlich davon automatischer Crawler der jetzt von mir aus dieser pace Seiten absucht eben nicht die Inhalte sehen kann,
ja weil der kann jetzt nicht anfangen das Passwort zu erraten
das heißt du automatische Indizierung und so davor war die Daten ganz gut geschützt auch die die hochgeladenen Dateien sind immer in passwortgeschützten
Archiven was also so eine automatisierte Erkennung durch den monitoring tatsächlich sehr wirksam.
Verhindern konnte an dieser Stelle also ich wäre jetzt über also ich wäre jetzt überrascht.
Oder ich wäre überrascht gewesen wenn oder in Verden interessiert gewesen mit welchem monitoring betonen sie jetzt diese.
Veröffentlichungen vorher hätten erkennen sollen.
Ich denke letztlich geht es ja hier auch nicht da droben also der Vogel verziert sicherlich gekommen aber das,
nicht so sehr. Die Frage ist halt ihr was was ist der Prozess also,
wie reagiert man wenn man überhaupt das erste mal drauf hingewiesen wird ja was hat man dann für ein Prozessablauf im Punkto Information rausfinden was,
könnte ich ihr eine potenzielle Bedrohung sein und daneben die entsprechende Benachrichtigungen und Sicherheitsempfehlung rauszugeben aber da halt so nackt
rum zu stehen und zu geben zu müssen also erstmal zu behaupten man man wüsste ja davon um dann wiederum zu geben zu müssen dass man überhaupt nichts davon weißt
das wird natürlich ein bisschen dünner ne.
Reinlich und dann stolz erklären dass man schon zum Freitagnachmittag daraufhin hingewirkt hat dass der Twitter Account geblockt wurde ja nicht nur der gewann mehrere Twitter Accounts sie damit in Zusammenhang stehen die teilweise auch seit Jahren irgendwie da ihr Unwesen treiben
also auch auf diesen Twitter-Accounts eben gleich mal
sprachliche Hinweise auf dieses YouTube Umfeld oder so.
Auch Bezüge die eine relativ klare Ausrichtung zu diesem,
Mobbing Spielereien da haben die dir bestimmte YouTube Leute da regelmäßig irgendwie anführen oder so.
Ich bin da na ja betroffen eben private account.
Das ist aber das ändert ist halt also ich meine ihr könnt euch selber fragen wie sieht's bei euren,
wie sieht's bei eurem privaten Accounts aus ihr habt ihr wirklich eine Trennung zwischen privat und geschäftlich na das haben natürlich diese Politiker genausowenig der mir kein
Verdienst Handy oder so wo sie jetzt irgendwie ganz klar trennen was dass ich Fraktionen nur auf dem Handy Familie nur auf dem handy.
Problematisch offenbar schützen Sie
Schützen viele der betroffenen Person ihre privaten Account nicht vernünftig haben irgendwelche schlechten Passwörter auf ihren E-Mail Account haben schlechte Passwörter auf ihren Twitter-Account nutzen vielleicht auch diese diese Facebook Logins wo man sich einmal bei Facebook einloggen und dann überall sonst eingeloggt wird
sehr gut kann es sein dass hier auch das ein oder andere Passwort mittels Social Engineering erlangt wurde da weiß man bis jetzt noch nichts drüber.
Also es gibt noch keinen der sagt hier ja ich wurde gefischt aber würde mich auch nicht wundern wenn sich das irgendwann zeitnah herausstellt die Untersuchungen dauern ja an bis jetzt wissen die wenigsten wie es wirklich passiert ist.
Dann.
Was wie reagiert die Politik richtig schlau also schauen uns das an seit diese liegt sind streckenweise.
Monate und Jahre alt na wir sehen ja geil versagt der Angreifer ja die timestamps in den Garten gelassen wo man sieht okay hier das ist irgendwann im Juni 2017 passiert oder wann auch immer.
Und bis heute sind diese Daten nicht aus dem Netz.
Und wenn sie jetzt irgendwann viele viele Monate nach Veröffentlichung irgendwann aus dem Netz verschwinden dann sind die eh schon überall da wo sich jemals jemand dafür interessiert hat ja das ist jetzt Zahnpasta die aus der Tube raus ist.
Und und und was fordert natürlich direkt als allererstes irgendwo ein Hinterbänkler schwach matt von der CDU hat gewonnen unbedingt.
Was ein Quatsch was wollen wir jetzt machen wollen die jetzt hier diesen armen YouTube kocadag doxen und sagen haha deine Handynummer ist aber hier und und du wohnst da und daher ist wenn im Zweifelsfall früh genug rausfinden weil
weil wie gesagt ich darf von ausgehe wenn sich jetzt jemand mal wirklich hinsetzt dann wären die nicht lange brauchen bis sie den haben ne.
Ich gehe mal also so meine es kann sein.
Also wahrscheinlich hat diese Person jetzt echt alle Beweise die noch irgendwo zu Hause liegen liegen in in panischer Manier verbrannt oder so aber wer so den Mund aufmacht ja.
Der hat im Zweifelsfall auch im Klassenzimmer angegeben und und sonstwo also das würde mich jetzt echt wundern so wenn.
Kann sein technisch wie gesagt ist es ja nicht schwer da alles zu verschleiern aber so insgesamt vom tätertyp aus diese dieser Geltungsdrang mal schauen.
Aber das letzte was hier jetzt helfen würde wer hat back to the letzte was da was bringt und da merkt man auch wirklich entweder also ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen dass jemand ernsthaft das noch.
Vertreten kann soll ich glaube dass die Ernst selbst im Selbstfahren eigenen Scherben stehen immer noch sagen ok jetzt hier offensiv Möglichkeiten für für die Deutschen für die deutschen Cyber.
Institutionen oder Sonne es ist wirklich einfach nur unsinnig vielmehr natürlich klar wir sehen.
Wie verwundbar.
Im Prinzip diese gesamte Privatsphäre Vertraulichkeit und so weiter von unseren Abgeordneten ist wenn sich mal jemand mit ein bisschen Geduld und Spucke hinsetzt.
Das zeigt doch nur dass wir nicht ein Problem in unseren offensiven Fähigkeiten haben sondern es zeigt dass wir in Normans Problem in unserer defensiven Ausrichtung haben.
Und da sehe ich natürlich auch muss ich sagen die die Rolle der Provider.
Warum können Leute offenbar immer noch mit schlechten Passwörtern irgendwelche Accounts gestalten warum werden Menschen nicht vielleicht auch einfach gezwungen.
Eine ernstzunehmende Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung zu verwenden klar mag immer noch sein dass in bestimmten Konstellationen.
Hier dann Unsicherheiten sich ergeben oder so aber ganz ehrlich die meisten Leute betreiben ihre Privataccount doch einfach mal.
Ziemlich schlecht geschützt und wir könnten zu einem gewissen Grad auch die Provider,
höhere Anforderungen haben das müsste halt koordiniert sein damit man damit das nicht zum Wettbewerb Nachteil wird aber da ist auf jeden Fall noch,
Luft nach oben und ich würde mir wünschen dass wenigstens jetzt ein paar Lehren nicht nur von den Betroffenen Prominenten und Politik angezogen werden.
Sondern auch von euch liebe Privatperson die im Prinzip auch diesen Risiko ausgesetzt sind fange an mit den Passwörtern.
Genau erzähl mir doch mal bisschen,
was man jetzt eigentlich selber tun kann weil das ganze hat ja gezeigt wieder hier sind Hürden überwunden worden die vielleicht,
gar nicht erst da waren oder zumindest nicht besonders hoch oder sicher aufgestellt waren und da gibt's einfacher Lehren die man glaube ich hier ziehen kann.
Genau Passwort also das hat sich so inzwischen rumgesprochen sollte nicht erreichbar sein
ja sollten irgendwo aufgeschrieben stehen sollte nicht im imported unter der Tastatur kleben sollte nicht irgendwie der Name deines Hundes und dein Geburtsdatum sein sondern im Zweifelsfall einfach so lang wie möglich
und so mein Fall gerne auch noch mal so zufällig wie möglich das aller.
Gibt ja mittlerweile Passwort-Manager die einem dieses ganze Erstellen von Passwörtern auch
abnehmen so teilweise auch wissen welche Vorlieben bestimmte Webseiten haben und dementsprechend dann auch irgend so ein random String erzeugen,
geht nicht darum dass man sich das merkt und selber ein Tipps geht darum dass man sowas in einem Passwortmanager quasi in einem separaten verliest ablegt dafür ein Passwort hat das vielleicht auch regelmäßig ändert und.
Dann kann man im Prinzip überall was komplett anderes.
Genau das ist tatsächlich eine der wichtigsten Empfehlungen also man will überall ein unterschiedliches Passwort haben.
Einfach weil man ja davon ausgehen muss dass jedes einzelne Passwort unter Umständen verlorengeht wenn man also jetzt so ein Passwort safe hat dann kann man diese vielen unterschiedlichen Passwörter in einem Safe an zentraler Stelle sichern,
und mit einem einzelnen Passwort wiederum Zugriff auf alle bekommen das heißt man hat einerseits die wunderschöne Funktion
überall mit einem Passwort reinzukommen nämlich mit dem Passwort zu seinem Passwort safe gleichzeitig aber überall ein unterschiedliches zu haben und diese Wiederverwendung von Passwörtern ist immer noch,
das größte Problem die Leute eben von einer kleinen Sicherheit Schwankung zu einer radikal großen kommen ja ich es gibt ja diese wunderschöne Seite herbei pinpoint von Treuhand wo man sich im Prinzip.
Zu E-Mail-Adressen oder zu Domain sagen lassen kann ob es dazu schon einmal Sicherheit Schwankung gab und die die durchschnittliche E-Mail-Adresse die du da eingibst ist jetzt nur so ein Erfahrungswert die kommt da irgendwo zwischen 3 Uhr und 7 Uhr mal drin vor.
Und das steht in der Regel schon seit Jahren,
deine E-Mail-Adresse und dein Passwort weil du nur eins hast in in 20 Stellen im Internet und alles was Leute machen müssen ist diese E-Mail-Adresse mit dem Passwort kombinieren.
Und sich egal wo anmelden weil du Idiot eben überall das gleiche Passwort hast also Passwörter wiederzuverwenden ist.
Das größte Problem was du dir eintreten kannst besonderer wichtiger Schutz sollte natürlich für deine E-Mail Passwort gelten weil über dein E-Mail Passwort lassen sich im Zweifelsfall alle anderen Passwörter zurücksetzen.
Zu den zu den E-Mails würde ich ihm eigentlich direkt mal weiter es empfiehlt sich,
Accounts für die passwortwiederherstellung zu haben ich habe ja gerade gesagt Donald Trump hatte seinen Twitter-Account auf irgendwie Donald Trump at gmail.com registriert,
das ist schlecht weil klar ist dass das im Zweifelsfall auf seine primäre E-Mail-Adresse ist.
Das heißt was weiß ich das jetzt deine deine primäradresse und jetzt hast du eine zweite Adresse auf die duale diese Accounts registriert.
Die du aber für normale Korrespondenz einfach überhaupt nicht benutzt das heißt die Leute wissen gar nicht dass du diese E-Mail-Adresse hast die kann von mir aus ihrer zufällige zufällige Zeichen als er irgendetwas sein und darauf sind alle dein Account registriert.
Wenn also jemand deine deine primäre E-Mail-Adresse übernehmen sollte kann er wenigstens nicht deine ganzen anderen Account übernehmen.
Wenn man das ganze noch ein bisschen auf die Spitze treiben möchte,
ich meine ich bin deiner im Paranoia Bereich sehr elegant sind z.b. so catch-all E-Mail Adressen also catch-all bedeutet Dir gehört eine ganze Domain.
Ja und jetzt sagst du unter dieser Domain gibt es.
Von mir aus drei passt drei Postfächer was weiß ich info@spamathers.com oder sowas.
Und einer davon ist jetzt irgendwie deine primäre E-Mail-Adresse unter der du die ganze Zeit agierst.
Und die andere Nutzer was weiß ich geschäftlich at oder oder oder was weiß ich Mailingliste nett oder sonst was ne da richtest du dir in die verschiedene Accounts unter deiner Domain ein und dann machst du einen bestimmten Account den definierst du als den catch all account,
und jetzt kannst du.
Im Prinzip beliebige Accounts vor deinem et oder du kannst sofort ein at-Zeichen beliebige Zeichen setzen.
Und E-Mails die an irgendeine beliebige E-Mail-Adresse gehen die eigentlich nicht definiert ist landen dann in dem catch all account.
Also Beispiel du warst als ich du machst jetzt irgendwie ein Konto bei Facebook auf und dann sagst du halt okay.
Der dieses Konto registriere ich auf Facebook account at Domain und jetzt schick Facebook die Bestätigung dass landet in deinem catch all account
warum ist das schön du hast du kannst nachher wenn die Evelin einer anfängt dich tot zu spammen kannst du dir die E-Mail-Adressen einfach einstellen sein ey pass auf wenn dahin was kommt einfach bitte sofort löschen,
ja falls du kriegst deinen Spam Problem ganz gut in den Innen in den Griff das andere ist Facebook account at Domain,
ist kein valida Account auf dem E-Mail-Server das heißt selbst jemand der weiß das dass die E-Mail-Adresse ist auf die der Account registriert.
Kann nicht.
Diesen Login Namen nutzen und dazu ihren Passwort erraten der müsste also erstmal den wirklichen Account herausfinden unter dem du eben diese unter dem du diese E-Mails empfängt habe ich empfing habe ich das gut.
Das müssen wir die eine Hälfte in die also brauchst du noch das Passwort aber du hast schon man den Login Teil schonmal auch verschleiert.
Das ist übrigens unterschätztes unterschätzter sich als Faktor wenn man einfach mal den Login Teil auch nicht hat,
wird das finde das sehr schön teilweise gehen Dienste inzwischen dazu über dass sie deinen Benutzernamen trennen.
Also oder.
Von der E-Mail-Adresse.
Trennen von E-Mail-Adresse und Benutzername also du hast was was ich du bist Kunde 123 unter der E-Mail-Adresse ADAC.
Aber dein Login ist ein frei wählbarer Benutzername und frei wählbares Passwort das hilft einfach.
Dann wissen die Leute nämlich z.b. nicht an welche wohin sie in count password-recovery machen sollen oder sind einfach so Kleinigkeiten.
Die dabei helfen es den Leuten schwieriger zu machen keine einzige dieser Möglichkeiten.
Eltis ist irgendwie der dir das eine Sicherheitsfeature was du haben musst und es ist einfach die Kombination aus allen die insgesamt an das Sicherheitsniveau hochzieht am wichtigsten ohnehin.
Leider immer noch von den wenigsten angeboten und von noch weniger Leuten genutzt Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Ganz wichtige Angelegenheit du willst eigentlich nicht dass man in deinen Account rein kommt nur unter Angabe des Account Namens und des Passwortes weil dein Passwort ist scheiße und dein Passwort ist überall das gleiche.
Sehr elegant,
verschiedene Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung Möglichkeiten die haben alle auch wieder ihre Schwächen ja diese SMS können theoretisch abgefangen werden
diese Google
Authenticator Codes könnten dir gestohlen worden sein die die arrestato uns haben ihre Schwächen die University second Hector Dinger die du in den USB stecken kannst da gibt's auch Angriffsmöglichkeiten drauf aber es ist immer eine
Sicherheitsmaßnahme mehr und eine Sicherheitsmaßnahme mehr.
Besser als eine Sicherheitsmaßnahme weniger und es macht halt ein Unterschied ob du in so einem Dock fliegt nur mit deiner Telefonnummer drin stehst weil irgendein anderer idiot gehackt wurde oder ob du derjenige bist,
der vielleicht unter Umständen damit der mit der Hose runter steht oder der schuld daran ist dass die E-Mail-Adresse von Angela Merkel auf einmal Meter Internet steht nicht die mehr als Handynummer.
Ja also hat dich auch für nicht nicht für alle immer problemlos machbar klar die meisten Leute haben irgendwie ein Mobiltelefon.
Ist dann.
Mobiltelefon.
Bei Kindern dann immer schon mal so eine Sache also E-Mail-Account sind auch noch mal speziell problematisch weil üblicherweise da wo man hustet.
Auf gerade das Ändern von Passwörtern an sich auch sehr schwierig ist so bzw Login Prozess ja meistens immer nur von einem Programm für dich
vorgenommen wird und das nicht so ein aktiver einlogg Mechanismus ist wie man den von Webseiten kennt.
Ja du bist du bist aber in der Welt in du bist in du bist in der Welt wo man noch einmal Useragent benutzt wie es sich für viele Leute gehört es gibt natürlich auch noch die Welt profile.
Wo viele Webmail benutzen ja und da kannst du also viele Leute benutzen z.b. Gmail kann man ihn eigentlich nicht verübeln gilt also kann man schon aber zumindest aus.
Man soll ich mal man hat dann halt immer Gmail.
Ist jetzt nicht die schlechteste Wahl ja doch ist es aber da da da arbeiten wenigstens vernünftige Leute an der Sicherheit für diese Account sie hat die haben.
Aber los auf der einen Seite sprichst du von catch-all E-Mail Adressen die man sich einrichtet was in der Regel ein Privileg eines selbst betriebenen Mail Setups ist weil man das so als Dienstleistungen selten bekommt fällt mir zumindest nichts ein wo ich sagen kann.
Ja stimmt.
Nimm mal eine Domain und gib mir mal die ganze Domain als e-mail Zugang.
Gmail aber machen übrigens ne geht.
Alle seine Gmail.
Du kannst du nein du kannst du kannst eine du melden.
Ich will alles erziehbar haben.
Gmail catch all.
Nee du kannst Gmail als Mailserver für deine Domain verwenden und gehst du hin
kaufst du Domain was kostet ummelden wenn es mit de Domain ist sowas wie 6 € im Jahr
und dann nutzt du die diese Gmail Webmastertools oder was auch immer und setz dann als MX Record den Mailserver von Gmail und dann dann geht das ja dann hast du Gmail Look-and-Feel auf deinem.
Auf deinem auf deiner privaten dumme man darf natürlich nicht vergessen wenn die Vertraulichkeit deiner E-Mails dir am Herzen liegt dann bist Du natürlich schlecht beraten bei einem Unternehmen was die Inhalte deiner E-Mails für Werbung auswertet ja
immer noch mal so sekundäre Gedanken die man da haben sollte wenn aber deine Sorge ist dass jemand anderes sich.
Dein E-Mail-Account auf macht ne dann bist Du natürlich unter Umständen besser bei GMail aufgehoben als wenn du den E-Mail Server selber betreibt aber auch andere E-Mail-Anbieter ich finde es auch nicht verwerflich wenn man sagt
ich gebe einfach mal 1 € im Monat aus für E-Mail es gibt ja ernstzunehmende E-Mail Anbieter.
Ja gut aber aber gerade bei denen sie versicherte weiß jetzt nicht ob sich das jetzt geändert hat aber bei posteo hatte ich zwar schon mal gefragt zu ja was ist denn hier mit eigener Domäne man so nehmen wir aus Prinzip nicht so also das ist da so unterschiedliche Philosophien da muss man irgendwie auch noch mal.
Kann sein aber ich bin mir relativ sicher dass es dass es dass diese E-Mail Anbieter sich das auch nicht entgehen lassen.
Liebe privacy Liebe privacy-aware Mailanbieter die vielleicht hier auch bei Logbuch Netzpolitik reinhören
denk doch mal drüber nach so ein so ein so ein genauso einen Linus kompatibles privacy Angebot zu machen so All-you-can-eat hier Domain reinklicken Pipapo und dann
hat man genau eine gute Unterstützung für diesen ganzen Catcher.
Und dann noch was machst du schönes hier kombiniert mit so in Anführungszeichen Webvisitenkarte ne also.
Gibt's dann unter der Domain noch eine kleine Seite kannst du irgendwas reinschreiben nimmst du so ein Markdown Website generate a oder so dann sind die Leute doch erstmal halbwegs.
Halbwegs gut unterwegs.
Das war jetzt die Domain im Web Browser aufruft und dann kriegt man so eine.
Ja klar wenn du.
Kerninformation oder sowas ne kleines Päckchen fiel mir brauchen die Leute doch eigentlich gar nicht und aber normal wenn es ein bisschen jetzt in dieses catch-all,
vertieft entscheidend ist dass es nicht ein,
ein Account gibt der vollständig übernommen werden kann und wo dann einfach aller Tage Abend ist ja wenn jetzt deine Haupt E-Mail Account an dem alles hängt
kannst jetzt eine kurze Sekunde nachdenken welche Accounts du dann alle los bist weil die alle zurückgesetzt werden können das ist also das größte Unheil was dir überhaupt passieren kann weil du da eben alles auf einem Haufen liegen hast,
deswegen auch niemals diese Facebook authentication verwenden ist ja auch eine ein ein ein Pilzbefall im in,
dass du dich auf für ihren neuen Dienst anmelden möchtest und die sagen ja du kannst jetzt hier den langwierigen Prozess mit E-Mail-Adresse und dem ganzen Theater über dich ergehen lassen oder aber,
wir locken dich ein über Facebook geile Sache ne du bist ja schon bei Facebook eingeloggt mit anderen Worten wir gehen Facebook die macht dich dort einzuloggen und weil du dich den ganzen Tag bei Facebook ein und ausloggen hast oder Facebook das denkbar schlechteste Passwort
und ein Angreifer kriegt wenn er dein Facebook Zugang hat einfach noch was weiß ich denn fitness-tracker und was weiß ich was die Leute noch alles nutzen,
kostenlos obendrauf.
Ja das ist so eine.
Amazon Startup solche für eine gewisse Zeit gewesen dass jeder der sozialen mal so einen neuen Dienst ausprobieren wollte sich diese ganze User management
und Security Klimbim was damit zusammenhängt sparen wollte und dann einfach gesagt hat Margot Block ich doch mit dem Twitter oder mit dem Facebook-Account ein hast du ja wahrscheinlich eh und dann spar ich mir das alles
also ich habe.
Habe ich einen einzigen Dienst habe ich mich mal erniedrigt tatsächlich über meinen Twitter-Account mich einzuloggen weil sie keine andere Option genutzt haben das dann aber auch wieder rückgängig gemacht
grundsätzlich bin ich da ganz auf deiner Seite mache ich das nicht also ob das ist auch gut versteckt da steht da drin signup with E-Mail was hat und wie keiner so richtig versteht aber das ist
genau das was damit gemeint.
Also wir haben
jetzt überall unterschiedliche Passwörter die sind ein paar 40 wir haben einen getrennten Account für die passwortwiederherstellung auf dem wir unsere ganzen Accounts registriert sie haben zwei Faktor Authentifizierung und den wir können die Facebook ausdehnte cation eh nicht benutzen weil wir ja gar kein Facebook Account haben.
Dann fangen wir an und machen uns Gedanken über unser E-Mail Setup wir deaktivieren HTML E-Mails wir deaktivieren das Nachladen externer Inhalte.
Und,
dann hatte das hat uns auch den Vorteil dass man die meisten Spam-E-Mails dann noch mal kurz bei der Arbeit anschauen kann und nicht peinlich berührt sein muss weil einer die ganze Zeit Körperteile entgegen gestreckt werden.
Was guckst du denn für E-Mail.
Ich bin da ist auch so einer Spamliste von chirurgischen Interessengruppe.
Vorsicht Vorsicht mit anhängen und links ja insbesondere vorsicht bei E-Mails die man nicht erwartet hat.
Anhänger klar da geht die Thematik los mit diesem ganzen,
mit diesem ganzen Ransomware Trojaner die gerne in Drop Assault Word oder Excel Dateien mit Makros haben
wir klicken nicht auf Anhänge die wir nicht bestellt haben ne und wir kriegen auch nicht auf links das übrigens sollte man sich grundsätzlich angewöhnen.
Es ist ein großes Problem
das im Rahmen der Nutzerfreundlichkeit den Leuten immer so I Handlungsoption als schöner grüner Button angeboten werden soll ja du
du kriegst eine E-Mail von was weiß ich von Paypal oder deiner Bank oder sonst was und da kommt immer diese aufhören und klicken Sie hier um das zu tun was wir von ihnen wollen ja es ist sehr schlecht die Mensch
zu trainieren dass sie das tun egal wer euch auffordert
irgendwohin zu kommen klicken Sie hier wenn PayPal oder Amazon oder sei es eure Mutter oder euer Vater euch auffordert irgendwo auf einen Link in eine E-Mail zu kriegen machte
macht es euch zu einer grundsätzlichen Angewohnheit in euren Web-Browser zu gehen und die Adresse einzugeben,
ja das mussten wir erst musst einfach in der im Kopf drin sein er gibt diesen schönen diesen sehr schönen Satz,
Amateure üben solange bis sie es richtig machen können.
Profis üben solange bis es nicht mehr falsch machen können und das ist genau das ist genau das entscheiden wir klicken nicht auf links in E-Mail niemals.
Wir geben die Ziele so ein.
Mit ein.
Weißt du dass da was zu E-Mail zusagen HTML Hammer deaktiviert externe Inhalte nachts an.
HTML an sich ist ja erstmal kein Verbrechen sondern das Problem sind verlinkte Bilder na also diese externen Inhalte sind das Problem HTML.
Ja aber frag mal.
Super Idee gewesen.
La frag mal wie heißt der Sebastian Schinzel er hat auch auf dem Kongress noch mal intorq über die Felge Harley braucht kein HTML in E-Mail zu lass es lass es lieber sein alles weg.
Macht schön ohne Updates Updates kommen nicht ohne Grund spätestens seit,
wannacry sollten das alle gelernt haben Updates kommen nicht ohne Grund da sind schöne Sicherheitsupdates für euch dabei immer mal wieder macht es euch zur Angewohnheit dass alle eure Systeme auf dem aktuellen Stand sind.
Schalte die Location Übermittlung überall auf,
da gibt es keine Ahnung gibt immer noch Leute die irgendwie mit jedem Tweet mein bekannt geben zu müssen wo Sie sich gerade aufhalten.
Hoya.
Also der fragst du dich auch mit also gut bei mir ist das rein beruflich schon ein NoGo dass ich irgendwie sagen wo ich mich aufhalte abermann,
so der das gibt so wunderschöne Tools auch ja wo du.
Gerade Battlefield Veteran in welcher Bahn Sie gerade sitzen oder in welchem Flugzeug wo du sowas kannst ja wunderschön automatisiert auswerten das will man doch einfach gar nicht abgesehen davon.
Das wird das dann eben auch immer wieder
verloren geht in diesem Account System ist auch ein Teil dieser leaks Javan sich Personen wo aufgehalten haben von wo ihr welche password reset stattgefunden haben oder so findet sich auch in diesen
in diesen Daten wieder sowieso die Apps haben eine ganze Reihe an,
Einschränkungen und privacy Option das ist eine ekelhafte Arbeit sich da sich da durchzukämpfen aber das zeigt euch vor allem mal
was diese App alles an Daten über sammeln und speichern da kann man überall schön sagen
nein ich will nicht dass ihr das speichert nein ich gebe dieser App kein Zugriff auf einem eine Location Daten eine schöne Übung übrigens in iOS ist das relativ gut ermöglicht wo man sich dann zuschauen kann welche App hat auf welche,
Daten
Zugriff und zwar waren ja also was weiß ich eure radfahr Tracking App hat Zugriff auf eure Location Daten während ihr die App benutzt ja.
Das leuchtet ein Seemann wenn ihr euer Fahrradstrecken wollt ihr Fahrradfahrt dann muss die app darauf zugreifen können ist natürlich ärgerlich wenn sie es nachher in die Cloud lädt und ihr damit die geheime Militärbasis verratet auf der ihr Fahrrad gefahren seid.
Vorläufen die Sachen doch.
Ja wir laufen die Sachen leider genau.
Und es ist sensibilisiert einfach auch mal dafür.
Was da alles wo an Daten einfällt also alles schön immer wegklicken was geht was geht was geht und vor allem dann auch mal überlegen brauche ich diese Apps überhaupt ne
und wenn ich dir sowieso schönes immer darf zugreifen auf ihre Location Daten auch wenn die App nicht läuft so nee wieso.
Zugriff auf Mikrofon und solche Sachen natürlich auch immer große Probleme.
Alles alles das anklicken und sei wegklicken und sei es nur damit ihr auch ein Bewusstsein dafür bekommt was diese App eigentlich alles macht.
Datensparsamkeit Datensparsamkeit finde ich auch noch wichtig ja wenn diese diese Account dir halt über die Jahre verwendet ja die.
Die die die da sammelt sich so viel an ja diese Twitter DMS die man sich irgendwann mal geschrieben hat vor 10 Jahren
E-Mail Simon sich vor Jahren geschrieben hat das ist ja alles noch da das braucht ihr nicht das wartet da im Prinzip nur darauf dass ihr Knicker mal da rein kommt unser Akku mal hier
E-Mail interessanten Zoff gehabt mit dem Ex-Freund vor sieben Jahren dann aber spannend was haben Sie sich denn da für Bilder geschickt aber oyoyoy wird es wollt ihr nicht,
das wollt ihr nicht also löschen löschen löschen löschen löschen bzw von mir aus daneben Lokal archivieren.
Und damit sind wir dann natürlich beim Schutz der Daten auf euren Geräten.
Hier nämlich immer dass das wunderschöne Beispiel.
Laptop in der U-Bahn liegen gelassen finde ich ehrlich gesagt regelmäßig also einmal im Jahr.
Zu Laptops oder was.
Nein nenne die Aushänge von irgendwelchen Mensch.
Achso.
Die ihr die ihre Diplomarbeit Doktorarbeit Bachelorarbeit Masterarbeit hast du nicht gesehen auf ihren Laptop innerhuber in erinnert RAM haben liegen lassen ja und was stellen die fest sie haben keine Backup.
Also.
Backup sorriso Backups wäre kein Backup kein Mitleid ja da da braucht man nicht gar nicht.
Das war schon seltener geworden ne also jetzt wo die Leute den Kram in die Cloud reinschreiben.
Ja geile Idee Cloud Backup ne also ich meine wenn der gleiche von von einen ein interessierter Youtuber übernimmt dein Account reden dann ist natürlich so ein Cloud Backup auch das erste was du dem offen Tablette liefern möchtest ne aber.
Damit kommen wir natürlich zu dem entscheiden. Daten gehören verschlüsselt und zwar alle,
das gilt für die Festplatte oder hoffentlich inzwischen SSD in euren Computern.
Ihr wollt da eine full Disk encryption haben gibt es von jedem Betriebssystem Freihaus bei Windows wie heißt das bei Windows.
Services in Hietzing Name für bei Windows sein ich auch egal jedes Betriebssystem mit dem ihr im Zweifelsfall arbeitet hat diese Option einer full Disk encryption und ihr möchtet sie
verwenden damit nämlich wenn ihr euren Rechner verliert die Daten darauf vor den vor der Finderin geschützt sind,
das gleiche wollt ihr bei externen Speichermedien haben also die USB-Sticks dir mit euch rum schleppt was ist das für eine Quelle ewiger Freude irgendwelche USB-Sticks die Leute irgendwo verlieren ja damit wurden ja damit würde ja
schon soviel aufgemacht und so viel gejoggt und so viel geliebt das geht doch auf gar keine Kuhhaut mehr.
Und natürlich auch eure Backups sollten verschlüsselt sein ja also ihr verschlüsselt bitteschön auf eine,
voll verschlüsselte Festplatte oder ihr verschlüsselt über CNET Lokal verschlüsselt oder von mir aus,
auch in eine Cloud dann aber bitte auch verschlüsselt ja man muss sich nicht schämen wenn die Backups voll verschlüsselt
Abend irgendwo bei Amazon liegen es gar keine so schlechte Idee weil eine ganze Menge im Internet wird kaputt gehen bevor jetzt irgendwie die Amazon Cloud Ihre Daten verliert das heißt da seid ihr ja natürlich.
Relativ gut aufgehoben sofern ihr eben darauf geachtet habe dass eure Daten da verschlüsselt.
Ja also Backup ist immer generell eine gute Idee aber wenn nur lokale Backups macht es halt gegen so ein paar
Problem Vektoren nicht gefeiert ne also Einbruch mit alles mal raus geklaut und da hilft einem auch das beste Backup nicht wenn es auf demselben Laster gerade die Wohnung verlässt
und hoffe das passiert keinem von euch aber sowas wie ein Wohnungsbrand ist zittere kann halt auch
solche Konsequenzen haben und man muss sich immer überlegen welchen Wert hat
die Anwesen Anwesenheit oder vielmehr welchen Schaden hat die Abwesenheit all dieser Daten ja sag mir schon das Beispiel diplomarbeit das sind ja so,
und.
Also nicht ohne weiteres zumindest replizierbar kostet.
Das ist replizierbar solange wie du es hast kannst du so oft CP eingeben wie du.
Jaja die meine Wände wenn die Arbeit halt weg ist ne also vielleicht wirds beim zweiten Mal ja besser aber unter Umständen muss ich halt auch noch mal in die Jahre hinsetzen
und das ist natürlich auch alles Lebenszeit mal ganz davon abgesehen das was dass ich belege und Verträge und was man heutzutage alles schon
primär digiterra digital vorhält naturlich sehr wichtig ist Buch halt.
Und da sind wir wieder bei Buchhaltung wer also ich habe das.
Er hat das glaube ich auch schon öfter erzählt ich bin ja bei dem Backup ich verfolge ja die Eichhörnchen Strategie eine Eichhörnchen weiße die verstecken überall Nüsse und zwar so viele die merken sich noch nicht mal mehr wo.
Sie finden diese ganzen isunny nur wieder weil sie überall da wo man welche verstecken könnte eben dann auch wieder danach suchen ja war ja lange Zeit ihr wie die Überlegung ob ob Eichhörnchen tatsächlich sich das alles merken.
Und genauso verfahre ich mit meinem Backup immer welche Wo bin wo wo sich ein geeignetes Versteck für einen verschlüsseltes Backup bietet dann lasse ich eins.
Und wenn dann irgendwann wenn Berlin abbrennt dann fahre ich eben irgendwo in Deutschland rum und wenn Deutschland irgendwann abbrennt dann kann ich noch im Internet interkontinental Reisen machen irgendwo werde ich noch an an Backups wiederkommen.
Habe ich auch schon gemerkt.
Ja und das kostet wenig Geld das kostet wenig Geld ich als ich Rebecca Platte 2 Terabyte ja.
Kostet 60 € da mein wir doch keine Gedanken drüber die nehme ich mach die voll und,
Soda das ist mit der freue ich mich doch irgendwann ja also im im Vergleich zu dem Schadenspotential den den ein vollständiger Daten das ein vollständiger Datenverlust bedeutet.
Ja wenn man mit dir so geteilten Ordner hat Alan dann auch mal irgendwelche Daten Köttel drin wo man sich fragt sowas was hat er denn jetzt hier schon wieder,
Sante ausgelagert aber ehrlich gesagt Linus ich glaube du machst das nur um dich wichtig zu machen oder hat ja soviel wertvolle Daten zu schützen.
Das ist gerade jetzt ist ihr 400MB was ich da reingelegt habe also machen wir jetzt hier nicht so einen Aufriss und unverschlüsselt ne.
DAK ich weiß immer noch nicht was geiles geile Körperteile drin sind.
Nee das steht doch.
Bist du dir deinen Chirurgie aber was sollen wir eingeworfen hat.
Aber ich würde jetzt ganz gerne nicht mehr weitere Details über meine Backup Strategien hier behandeln.
Gut bin aber geil.
Kann man passiert hat er dich was dem gerade anspricht was man auch mal ganz gut machen kann mehr so ein Bündelchen schnüren
vom Säufer vom von den wichtigen Sachen die man vielleicht für einen für den Neustart nach der Zombie Calypso braucht der schönes Bündelchen schnüren,
ordentlich verschlüsseln,
ordentliches Passwort dran dieses Passwort wieder nicht dein Standard Passwort und dann könnte man z.b. so ein kleines Bündelchen von Daten einfach mal an gute Freunde schicken und sagen bitte ignorieren.
Und wenn dann irgendwann der wenn dann irgendwann der Härtefall Eintritt dann kann man eben im Winter ohne Klamotten da anklingeln und sagen ey weißt du noch was du ignorieren solltest ja ich habe jetzt schon kann man sich vielleicht die wichtigsten.
Die wichtigsten Daten die man für einen Neustart nach der Zombie Apokalypse braucht dort.
Ja wollen wir mal über andere Sachen reden.
Ja genau ich glaube jetzt haben wir Rat und Ratschlag gegeben der haben den Hackerangriff aufbereitet.
Ich bin mal gespannt also ich meine also schlagen hier was die Prognose angeht zwei Sachen 22 Herz in meiner Brust einerseits eben lange Zeit unbemerkt.
Offenbar echt ein gutes Händchen und langen Atem.
Wer solange sowas unbemerkt macht hat im Zweifelsfall halbwegs akzeptable OpSec sodass.
Andererseits dieser dieser Geltungsdrang und dieses ausplaudern und diese Nachlässigkeit im veröffentlichen von,
timestamps Ansichten Rechtschreibung und so weiter das könnte dann am Ende zu Verhängnis werden deswegen Prognose wenn Sie die Person schnappen.
Dann über so dümmlich Haare Nachlässigkeiten wie zu oversharing Geltungsdrang und soweit.
5 € Tim oder nicht.
Ich wollte nur noch mal auf unsere ich wollte nur meinen meinen bisherigen Wetteinsätze irgendjemand zurückbekommen.
Naja mal gucken was ist jetzt noch offen brexit ne.
Brexit da werde ich damit da komme ich wieder auf eine schwarze Null.
Meinst du na ja schauen wir mal duden.
Ja eine eine Frage die uns oft gestellt wurde auch beim kleinen Freakshow hörertreffen auf dem 35 C3 ist ich will was tun wohin soll ich spenden.
Ich habe zuviel Geld wohin soll es abwerfen das natürlich eine legitime Frage und natürlich fällt hier jeden sofort ein die Metaebene und Logbuch Netzpolitik zu unterstützen aber es gibt auch noch andere
gute Ziele die man mal bedenken sollte.
Genau ich finde bei sowas also erstmal muss man bedenken.
Ihr könntet jetzt den Gedanken haben dass wir das irgendwie offen relativ antizyklisch machen wenn wir am 6. Januar auf einmal über Spenden reden wo doch gerade alle ihre weihnachtsspenden im letzten Monat des Jahres verballert haben.
Wir besprechen das aber jetzt nicht ohne Grund an denn viel wichtiger als so eine einmalige Spende.
Ist ein Dauerauftrag netzpolitik.org musste irrt sie ich weiß nicht wann das 80 oder 60000 € im Dezember einsammeln um das Jahr 2018 noch auf den grünen Zweig zu bekommen,
das ist richtig schlecht das heißt die haben da am Ende des Jahres noch mal richtig zittern müssen mussten irgendwie eine große Spendenkampagne fahren und mussten was als ich,
zumindest für einige Wochen oder Monate fürchten dass sie am Ende das Jahr nicht vernünftig abschließen.
Oder droht der Shutdown vielen USA.
Genau dann auf einmal kommt Donald Trump und schaltet nicht witzig org ab ne,
das will man nicht deswegen haben sagen ja alle Organisationen die,
so Spenden basiert arbeiten oder Spenden abhängig sind dass sie viel wichtiger Daueraufträge finn und genau deswegen sagen wir das jetzt am Anfang des Jahres und nicht am Ende.
Also ein Dauerauftrag ist für die für die Organisation die unterstützen wollt sehr viel wichtiger als eine einmalige groß.
Und lies das immer noch mal kurz erklärt warum eigentlich weil am Ende kommt ja dasselbe Geld bei raus es ist halt einfach so Mann.
Will ja quasi Ressourcen zum Einsatz bringen und man traut sich vielleicht auch mal was aber am Ende will man das nicht das Risiko klein halten
kleine regelmäßige Spenden signalisieren permanent 1 das ist vermutlich derita mit dem Jahr arbeiten könnt
heißt es viel sinnvoller kontinuierlich kleine Sachen zu Empfang
als immer drauf zu hoffen dass dann irgendjemand noch mal ein dickes Paket abwirft das schadet natürlich nichts am Ende des Jahres wenn das dann trotzdem auch getan wird aber,
hilfreicher ist es auf jeden Fall so einen kontinuierlichen Strom zu haben auch wenn er vielleicht der sich auskennt betreten.
Genau dann ist die Frage was ich ich tue mich relativ schwer wenn Leute sagen an wen soll ich denn mal Spenden ich finde wichtiger dass ihr euch überlegt.
Was kommt wo dabei rum also wofür spende ich für welche für welche politischen Ergebnisse für welche politischen Ziele und was unternehmen unterschiedliche Organisationen.
Um diese Ziele zu erreichen und diese Organisation haben mir einen track record die können ja sagen schau mal,
das haben wir erreicht uns sind
soundsoviel Euro in dem mit dem Jahr gespendet worden und das ist das was wir dafür getan haben bleiben wir beim Beispiel netzpolitik.org ja man kann sich das ja anschauen wie die über das Jahr,
dass die die Politik begleitet haben welche Recherchearbeiten dort geleistet wurden welche politische Berichterstattung da geleistet wurde
und war kann sich ja auch in den Transparenzbericht and anschauen wie viel Geld das gekostet hat und dann kann man sich überlegen aha
nee bin ich mit der Performance dieser Organisation zufrieden oder nicht.
Und wenn ich das bin dann sehe ich mein Geld dort gut investiert ich finde das sehr wichtig darüber nachzudenken dass dieses Geld was ich da ausgebe ja wenn ich irgendwohin Spende.
Dann möchte ich ja das gebe ich ja nicht weil ich weil die das gut gemeint haben sondern weil die das gut machen,
und weil ich möchte das mehr davon passiert und weil ich das als in investment,
meine Zukunft als Bürger dieses Landes sehe das z.b. netzpolitik.org weiterhin arbeiten kann und den die Politik auf diese Weise prägt.
Amir könntest aber natürlich auch sein dass ihr sagt hier Informationsfreiheit finde ich total wichtig ja ich finde es toll was Arne semsrott z.b. mit frag den Staat macht dann müsst ihr an die Open knowledge Foundation spenden
die die eben dieses und viele andere Projekte trägt könntet aber auch z.b. sagen naja.
Ich beobachte hier diesen Grundrecht Abbau der vom Bundestag Park betrieben wird.
Und es ist relativ klar dass die last line of defense die wir jetzt haben Verfassungsklagen sind.
Es ist es relevant dass dass diese Gesetze wieder zusammen gestutzt werden da brauchen wir ernsthafte Juristen da brauchen sie ja Menschen die an dieser Stelle jetzt arbeiten um das schlimmste,
an dem am Grundrecht Abbau zu verhindern na ja da gibt's eigentlich nur eine Organisation die da sofort in den Sinn kommt dass es halt die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte.
Man könnte sich z.b. auch fragen okay Level vielleicht mal nicht nur in Deutschland schauen was ist mit dem Grundrecht der Abbau in.
In anderen Ländern international und so ich meine Deutschland sind wir ja in der in der Angela angenehmen Position dass es das Wasser nur bis zum Hals steht da was ist mit was ist mit Ländern.
Der Türkei was ist mit Ländern wie den Saudi-Arabien was ist mit Ländern wie China wer engagiert sich hier für die Menschen die wie wir wissen.
Mit dem Tod bedroht sind ja und da natürlich auch.
Wir haben hier den digitalen Fokus im digitalen Bereich da kann man natürlich z.b. sofort an Amnesty International denken die auch mit gerade mit Claudio guarnieri
Wahnsinns menschenrechtskämpfer Team haben im Bereich der der Staatstrojaner die gegen Dissidenten in verschiedenen,
Ländern dieser Erde eingesetzt werden und Claudia leistet Arne seit Jahren beeindruckende Arbeit die eben auch,
durch eine Spende an Enes Amnesty International unterstützt werden kann wir haben Reporter ohne Grenzen.
Klar auch die sehr besonnen sehr besonders engagiert in in ihrem Bereich der ein sehr wichtiger ist auch Reporter ohne Grenzen dieses Jahr mit sehr,
mit sehr großen Erfolgen im Logbuch vertreten.
Wir haben epicenter works wenn ihr in Österreich seid oder euch um Österreich bemühen wollt auch da.
Eine durchaus eine Bedrohungslage erkenntlich die jetzt Unterstützung und Spenden erfordert Thomas Lohninger ist ja hier auch,
regelmäßig für euch da und berichtet davon epicenter works zu unterstützen,
bietet sich hier natürlich an in der Schweiz auch bei uns regelmäßig zu Gast das Team,
um Tiere mit der digitalen Gesellschaft Schweiz das wären jetzt so.
Die Organisationen die mir einfallen.
Die in diesem Jahr und auch in den vorangegangenen Jahren gezeigt haben dass sie einer Spende würdig sind.
Vielleicht kurzer Exkurs der CCC da gibt's eine Fördermitgliedschaft aber im CCC arbeiten ohnehin alle ehrenamtlich,
bezahlte Aktivismus ist bei uns aus guten Gründen verpönt das ist heißt nicht dass jeder der bezahlten Aktivismus betreibt
irgendwie zu kritisieren ist aber der cccs hat sich eben auf die Rolle festgelegt das nicht zu professionalisieren sondern eben das gesamte Engagement im Rahmen eines,
Ehrenamtes zu zeigen das heißt wenn ihr den ccccc spendet dann gehen geht euer Geld im Zweifelsfall in,
Community Arbeit den geht die Förderung von anderen IT Projekten da ist der CCC als Spender relativ großzügig und viel unterwegs da kann man unserem Vorstand echt,
noch mal auch danken für die für die für die Perspektiven,
diese da haben als für gleich mal kleinere Gruppen die Geld brauchen und die da vom CCC unterstützt werden mit wichtiger politischer Arbeit.
Aber auch da gibt es die Möglichkeit eine Fördermitgliedschaft zu erlangen ich würde aber wie gesagt gucken so bei den vorher genannten Organisationen da.
Habt ihr eben messbaren impact für euer Geld und da müsst ihr euch einfach nur überlegen welchen impact soll euer Geld haben und da könnt ihr.
Gute Anmerkung dazu also gerade was jetzt die Arbeit des Clubs betrifft also,
der Club nutzt halt das Geld was da reinkommt im vor allem auch mal um Gruppen zu unterstützen,
die jetzt vielleicht nicht so die Öffentlichkeit haben wo man auch einfach,
aus einer unmittelbaren Zusammenarbeit heraus weiß dass da gerade eine Notlage ist ETCS insofern delegiert man dann sozusagen auch noch das Wissens gibt's so die Gruppen die eben die Welt auch aufgezählt haben nahezu kontinuierlich mit einer bestimmten.
Kite das ganze unterstützen der Club Kommerz,
oft daneben auch um die Sonderfälle und kurzfristige sonderbedarfe was sicherlich auch sehr schön findest und bisschen noch mal so eine kleine Versicherung auch für die Zähne.
Auf jeden Fall also das ist will das nicht kleinreden Ich wollte mir ging es nur darum zu leben das Augenmerk darauf zu legen,
was tut diese Organisation mit dem Geld was ist der Track Record dieser Organisation,
und was möchte ich mit meinem Geld anfangen.
Allgemein wirklich vorsichtig wäre ich bei Organisationen die seit Jahren keinen nennenswerten Track-Record haben die vielleicht stets bemüht waren.
Aber selten mal wirklich ein Erfolg liefern konnten.
Und da würde ich auch vor allem sehr vorsichtig sein könnte ich echt sagen wenn man da an wenn die auch auf einmal anfangen mit unserer lösen.
Geschäftspraktiken ja es gibt irgendwie diese von einigen Angie aus ja schon diese Drückerkolonne am am Alexanderplatz ne die wo die Organisation offenbar Geld hat.
Um Leute raus zu schicken die dir irgendwie so eine so eine so eine Mitgliedschaft über helfen die dir dann nicht mehr los wirst.
Und genauso skeptisch wenn ich ehrlich gesagt auch bei Leuten die mit ihren welchen Abofallen Arbeiten die im Prinzip dadrin bestehen so hier du kannst bei uns folgendes tolles Buch oder T-Shirt oder sonst was kaufen oder
wir schenken es dir,
wenn du jetzt hier dich in unserer Abofalle begibst und daneben für den Rest deines Lebens wir von deinem Konto versuchen,
Geld einzuziehen bei solchen Geschäftspraktiken immer darauf an.
Leisten die eigentlich auch was für dieses Geld führen die die Änderung herbei die ich persönlich gerade in dieser Gesellschaft für notwendig halte oder,
sind die eben eher nur auf der Ebene gut gemeint und für gut gemeint glaube ich ehrlich gesagt,
steht uns das Wasser inzwischen ein bisschen zu hoch.
Sicherlich fallen euch noch mehr Organisationen ein fände ich auch super die in den Kommentaren zu nennen.
Weil ich natürlich ein bisschen jetzt schon weiß dass ich da wahrscheinlich irgendwelche,
besonders wertvollen Genossinnen und Genossen jetzt ausgelassen habe mir ging es auch eher darum,
euch dazu zu animieren zu überlegen was passiert da mit meinem Geld da werden da irgendwelche sitzen irgendwelche Leute rum.
Oder geht die los und erreichen die etwas.
Und diese Frage lässt sich am besten beantworten wenn man schaut was die Leute in der Vergangenheit gerissen haben so übrigens auch bei uns.
Was wir machen finde ich finde ich finde ich ganz wichtig dass Du zumindest was wir machen ist.
Im Prinzip so ein Infotainment wir unterhalten und informieren euch über das Geschehen wir geben euch einen Überblick wir versuchen euch für die Themen zu interessieren.
Ihr könnt uns sehr gerne dafür unterstützen aber bitte denkt daran dass ihr auch dorthin spendet wo eben auch die wirkliche notwendige Arbeit geleistet.
Und dann eben da wo es auch wirklich wirkt ja mir ist relativ egal wie viel Arbeit Leute irgendwo reinstecken mich interessiert das was am Ende bei rauskommt.
Da hilft auf jeden Fall bei all diesen Umsatz Ionen einschließlich Logbuch Netzpolitik.
So jetzt kann man endlich die 35 C3 Rückschau machen oder willst du überhaupt noch.
Wann Kongress redet der Tim immer gern.
Ja weil es in der Regel auch immer gut das zu erzählen gibt also hab da wenig schlechte Erfahrung gemacht.
Warst du nicht da.
Ich war da aber.
Es ist alles wie ein Nebel zog in rosa.
Nee ich habe dieses Jahr wirklich besser hingekriegt ja es war ja so ein bisschen.
Also wenn du gerade beim letzten Kongress wurde ich ja wirklich von vielen Bekannten und Freunden und nicht bekannten angesprochen dass sie sich Richtung Takt
3 nicht mehr unbedingt den Eindruck machte noch besonders gut im Saft zu stehen und dieses Jahr habe ich das glaube ich echt sehr viel besser hinbekommen.
Deutlich deutlich das kann ich bestätigen auf jeden Fall nein.
Insofern erinnere ich mich an den größeren Teiler.
Ja also 35C 335 Chaos kolliquation Kongress viele von euch werden dort gewesen sein viele sicherlich auch
nicht alle die da waren die auch bei kurzen hörertreffen da waren vielen Dank dafür auf vielen Dank für das
zahlreiche Feedback so auf den Fluren kurze dankeswünsche andere Hinweise das war wieder alles sehr zahlreich und
alles sehr willkommen und immer schön euch dann mal auch so direkt kennenzulernen.
Der Kongress ansich War II in Leipzig hintereinander und das versprach insofern schon mal interessant zu werden weil die Erfahrung immer gezeigt hat,
die zweite Veranstaltung in einem neuen Ort das ist die die eigentlich richtig interessant ist insofern haben viele auch den Vergleich gezogen z.b. zum 30 C3 außer II Event war in
Hamburg und DAAD 29.03.
In den Schatten stellte im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes das war deutlich zu sehen und meiner Meinung nach war es auch dieses Mal so also man hat,
Mann im Sinne von der ganze Club das ganze organisierende gewesen all die Leute die dort mitgeholfen haben sowohl die Orga als auch die Engel haben einfach dazu beigetragen
alle Lehren zu ziehen die so das letzte Jahr einmal ist Aufgabe im Buch geschrieben hat wir erinnern uns da,
ist zwar eigentlich alles recht gut gelaufen.
Aber es gab halt Schwierigkeiten einfach in der Anpassung an das Gebäude insbesondere so die Zuflüsse zu dem Vortrag Seelen hat sich viel gestaunt erzählen also man merkt da einfach.
Das hat zwar schon ganz gute Antworten geliefert worden aber eben noch lange nicht alle Fragen beantwortet waren und dass dich dieses Jahr wirklich super.
Der Kongress ist größer geworden nachdem alle Schulden von dieser dreiviertel Halle letzten Jahr was du camp artig daherkam
schwer beeindruckt waren kam dieses Jahr gleich noch mal so eine komplette Halle dazu also die Halle 2 wurde dann vollständig genutzt und ein dreiviertel der Halle 3
wurde sozusagen noch mal so zusätzlich als sm.de area also da wo sich Projekte niederlassen können Sichtbarkeit haben ihre eigenen Projekte zeigen und dran arbeiten können aber noch hinzugefügt und das
hat enorm dazu beigetragen weiterhin diesen hands-on Charakter des Kongresses zu unterstreichen was mich besonders freut
aber auch ganz konkret geographisch diesen Kongress zwischen der großen Linken und der großen rechten Seite feiner auszutarieren mit dem,
dass sich obwohl wenn es ja noch mal mehr Teilnehmer waren im letzten Jahr sich das für meinen Geschmack alles sehr schön verteilt hat also es gab eigentlich relativ selten
Gedrängel Stau Stress durch zu viele Leute am selben Ort es hat sich alles schön gleichmäßig über die ganze Location verteilt wie hast du das gesehen.
Fast ein bisschen zu gleichmäßig oder.
Na das wurde allgemein kritisiert dass der Kongress ja so entspannten Zeit und zum Hauptreisezeit Krisen aufgeben und so und was meinst du mit zu gleichmäßig also was was was hat ihr denn gefehlt.
Also Teile hatte ja,
hat dich da doch schon so ein bisschen in diesen in diesen Strecken vielleicht ein bisschen verlieren können
wenn man hatte jetzt nie den Eindruck dass jetzt zu viele Menschen um einen rum waren ich habe festgestellt dass
dass wir Schwierigkeiten hatten die,
oder teilweise Schwierigkeiten hatten z.b. sowas wie Saal 1 zu füllen ja es gab glaube ich nur relativ wenige Vorträge dort die.
Die voll waren also wo jetzt wirklich mal sal1 voll.
Das waren meistens dann Vorträge wo währenddessen auch nichts anderes ist ja oder die,
ja aufs aus verschiedenen Gründen vielleicht eine eine besondere Popularität beim Publikum hatten aber es war auf jeden Fall eher der selten Allertal dass der Saal 1 voll war und das kann natürlich damit zusammenhängen dass ihr eben viele andere große Seele hatten.
Ja einer mehr als letztes Jahr vor allem.
Genau und und dass die Zugangsregelung zu den Seelen tatsächlich ein bisschen verwirrend.
Warte ich mal die war notwendig gewesen um diese diese zu und Abflüsse aus den Seelen zu koordinieren der mir letztes Jahr,
große Probleme damit gehabt dass Leute rein und raus mussten aus den Seelen zum zum Wechsel der speakerin
dieses machen wir das gelöst das S1 quasi von der einen Seite einen Eingang gab und von der anderen Seite einen Ausgang da gab's eben streckenweise
der Verwirrung ist Lotta von den Saal auch nicht gefunden haben ne oder unterschätzt haben das jetzt von dem Tunnel aus Halle 3 noch irgendwie 200m gehen müssen bisschen wirklich im Saal sind so dass daneben Menschen das
ja tatsächlich unterschätzt haben wie lange das wie lange sie brauchen und vom einen Ende des Gebäudes an das andere zu kommen und in den in den in den Saal rein zu kommen,
das war glaube ich sowieso schon so ein bisschen sammeln weitesten Sinne ärgerlich Kiten mit den Leuten sich dann bisschen rum gib.
Ja gut muss man schauen welche Antworten man darauf findet oder Lehren daraus zieht können Sie auch sein dass wir das so optimiert haben das hat durchaus noch ein bisschen Kapazität nach oben frei ist was Sisal.
Könnte man dann im Detail draw nachdenken ob man vielleicht den Verkehrsfluss sich einfach umdreht sagen da wo es raus gehen rein aber das müssen wir es glaube ich hier auch nicht in der vollen Breite diskutieren,
grundsätzlich würde ich festhalten hat die Aufteilung sehr gut hingehauen also man die Flächen wurden
gut genutzt und an den Stellen wo es Änderungen gab hat es auf jeden Fall Wirkung gezeigt vielleicht schon zu viel Wirkung aber ich denke die Leute lernen auch langsam.
Dieses Gelände für sich zu erschließen das Glas großes weit aber man
wenn man dann irgendwann so ein bisschen von Kongress zu Kongress in diese Routine reinkommt was denn eigentlich wo stattfindet und mit welchen Wegen das verbunden ist
würzt das glaube ich finden zu maja der Kongress mittlerweile auch ein Schauplatz moderner Mobilität geworden.
Du meinst sirola Tage Leipzig.
Also das war wirklich eine eine eine Zweirad exhibition par excellence also von normalen Tretroller 1 bis zu
sophisticated electronic Mobile und wie alles im zu finden damit meine ich nicht nur diese elektrisch betriebenen Sessel und dick geworden
vor allem so E-Roller und sowas das hat auch noch.
Wo existiert das ich habe es nicht so wahrgenommen dass das permanent zu Konflikten führte.
Sicherlich wird aber irgendjemand mit jemand anderem zusammengestoßen sein aber es war zumindest kein großes
Problem so von daher war dieser Kongress auch auf eine wunderbare Art und Weise mobil und flüssig und so fand ich ganz geil.
Okay ja dann kommen wir mal zu deinem persönlichen zu deinem persönlichen Blick weil ich habe ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen Sorge dass du jetzt hier als Conny Sir die dich in die Details verlierst.
Das kann schon sein ja was meinst du mit meinem persönlichen Blick das ist ja auch mein persönlicher Blick.
Ja ist also mit deinem persönlichen Blick meine ich dir glaube ich schon öfter gesagt der es gibt nicht den Kongress sondern es gibt deinen Kongress.
Und da würde mich viel mehr interessieren was hast Du denn gemacht.
Ich habe mich weiter zurück genommen mich habe im Vorfeld das Sendezentrum mit an organisiert ist dann aber.
Relativ weit vor dem Kongress schon der eigentlichen
Community das überlassen das heißt das entwickelt sich von ganz alleine Sendezentrum war ganz nice dieses Jahr weil halt auch live Podcast stattfanden dann habe ich halt selber einen Podcast auf der Bühne auf dem Kongress auch durchgeführt am zweiten Tag.
Durch ein neues Format eröffnet
was schon ein paar Jahre bei mir auf Halde lag und was ich immer mal schon irgendwie ein Staat bringen wollte aber nie so richtig den richtigen Moment dafür gefunden habe da dachte ich mir,
die Gelegenheit lässt du dir jetzt nicht entgehen habe mir dann den Nikolaus und den Reinhard vom methodisch inkorrekt
geschnappt ja dieses Jahr keine große Show hatten und von da wo sich das ihre Belastung überschaubar sein würde und als Gäste eingeladen für die Pilotfolge des neuen Podcast Namen UKW.
UKW unsere kleine Welt,
ist ein weiterer Kanal der Metaebene den ich so über die nächste Zeit etwas zu entwickeln gedenke und der so ein bisschen der Ort ist wo ich
Dinge machen will die bisher eine anderen Formaten so recht ihren Raum nicht gefunden haben lasse das beruht bewusst wolkig weil.
Zimmer so ist das für Mama sowas anfängt dass ich das dann erstmal entwickeln muss bevor es irgendwas ist das wäre ich dann vielleicht in einem Jahr erzählen können was draus geworden ist.
Ansonsten habe ich gar nicht so viel gemacht ich habe mir
mein großer Spaß ist immer mit Leuten reden mit Leuten reden mit Leuten reden mit Leuten reden mit den Kongress als solchen anschauen wir funktioniert da Feedback zum Kongress und natürlich auch was ich sonst noch so ein Feedback bekomme zu meiner Arbeit einzusammeln und
ich nehme in zunehmendem Maße Teil an diesem Kongress dass das freut mich sehr früher war ich immer sehr
belegter mit eigenen Torx und Keynotes und keine Ahnung was man nicht alles so gemacht hat über die Jahre davon warst du ja nicht ganz.
Nee das stimmt musste ein bisschen mehr ich musste noch ein bisschen mehr machen.
Na muss noch du musst noch ran du bist ja noch jung da aber ich habe kein einziges Interview gegeben kein einzige Presse bearbeitet alles war.
Soll ich jetzt ein bisschen von meinem Kongress RC.
Ja mach mal ich kann mir vorstellen das war genau was anderes.
Ja Tag eins war Pressearbeit das haben wir also dass das Team was den Presseraum macht unter der,
Führung von Dante dem ich hier auch noch mal herzlich dafür danken möchte ist immer immer besser eingespielt wir kriegen das immer immer besser hin diesen.
Diesen Presse Ansturm an Tag 1 in den Griff zu kriegen haben abends war ja dann dieses.
Dieses hörertreffen Freakshow hörertreffen das fand ich auch mal sehr nett da ein paar nette Leute zu treffen oder besonders habe ich mich gefreut auch bei dem,
bei den Fritzsche hörertreffen ich hatte ja in der letzten Sendung dann sehr spät diesmal meine Kleine diversity Ticketaktion angekündigt.
Woher dann direkt noch.
In der Sendung Tim mit aufgesprungen ist und dann im kurz kurz nach der Sendung noch einige weitere Spender.
Was ich einerseits sehr schön fand was wir aber andererseits wie kurz kurz vorm Kongress das Problem gegeben hat ist auf einmal noch eine Reihe Kongressticket zu verschenken
und also will mich da nicht drüber beklagen ich glaube wir haben einer ganzen Reihe Menschen eine Freude bereitet und ich habe mich auch,
gefreut.
Einige davon eben bei diesem bei diesem Treffen da kennenzulernen weil das eben die ja die eine gute Möglichkeit war.
Sich mal ja privat zu treffen und vielleicht auch ein paar Minuten Zeit zum zum Quatsch.
Und ja also waren erstens konnte ich mich sehr davon überzeugen dass echt coole Leute diese Tickets bekommen haben und andererseits konnte ich mich auch davon überzeugen dass diejenigen die die da mit gespendet haben.
Auch echt coole Leute waren es ist einfach schön sowas zu sehen wenn wenn da so eine,
Solidarität der Leute untereinander entsteht und für für so coole Zwecke dann eine Gemeinschaft entschieden habe mich sehr gefreut deswegen noch mal herzlichen Dank allen die sich daran beteiligt.
Www.ticket.at in der letzten Endes rausgegangen aus der Serie diversity lottery.
Glaube sechs wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe wenn ich das richtig erinnere 246 77.
Jedes Jahr machen.
Das ganze hat noch eine unschöne also ich mache seit Jahren aber das ganze hat eine sehr unschöne Komponente weil da musst du natürlich auch absagen verschicken.
Esse etwas und schönere Teil davon aber.
Ja auch dass ich hatte sowieso den ein und das kurz vor dem Kongress tatsächlich noch mal der Mark geflutet wurde,
mit
Leuten die kurzfristig krank waren oder doch nicht kommen konnten aus familiären Gründen oder die dann gesehen haben ok ich habe ehrlich gesagt doch ein Ticket zu viel gekauft und kann das jetzt mal abgeben das finde ich
gut weil das hoffentlich allen leert die den Fehler gemacht haben sich von irgendeinem,
nicht besonders herzlich zu behandelnden Betrüger oder Abzieher irgendwie ein Ticket zu überhöhten Preis andrehen zu lassen wir sehen das ja immer wieder dass es Leute gibt die versuchen.
Die Tickets zu höheren Preisen anzubieten und es gibt wenig.
Was ich mehr verachte als sowas ja das ist wirklich eine eine unschöne,
eine unschöne Nummer und ich denke mit so Aktionen wie
in dem Fall dann doch wir sind ja auch nicht die einzigen die das gemacht haben gibt ja viele andere die auch ihre Tickets verschenken und dadurch dass man daneben zeigt das Lastminute am Ende doch echt alle immer noch ihre Tickets bekommen haben.
Können wir hoffentlich auch solche wirklich unschön versuche Geld zu machen irgendwie unterbinden.
Genau das.
Dann ich glaube am zweiten Tag war ja dann der Jahresrückblick.
Der Jahresrückblick hatte also Jahresrückblick des CCC mit Frank Rieger Constanze Kurz Erdgeist Nexus und mir der.
Sind immer ein bisschen in meinem Gefühl,
unter unser aller Stress an Tag 1 leidet ne wir haben wir haben beide wir haben alle fünf die wir da sind an an Tag Eins viel viel viel mit der Pressebetreuung zu tun das geht früh am Morgen los und das,
geht dann endet irgendwann am Abend das nimmt natürlich irgendwie Ruhe Sonntag noch mal vor so ein Sonntag noch mal vorzubereiten und deswegen sehe ich eigentlich,
zum.
Bisschen das der Jahresrückblick immer ein bisschen unter seinen Längen leidet ja weil wir eben weil ich weiß Frank hat am ersten Tag noch ein Tor gegeben übrigens auch ein großartiger Tocqueville ich gleich noch mal empfehlen.
Das da bin ich so ein bisschen traurig dass der das der Jahresrückblick dann da streckenweise eben seine Längen hat und.
Besonders traurig bin ich das wird dann am Ende durch die Erfahrung die Erdgeist sehr mühselig,
und akribisch zusammengetragen hat dann am Ende so durch gehetzt sind was insbesondere tragisch ist weil das auf ein.
Fehler zurückgeht in der Zeitmessung an meinem Computer ja wir wussten also der Tochter für uns solange sein.
Und dieser ich habe auf dem Moderator Screen so ein so ein so ein timer laufen und der läuft aber ab dem Moment wo du diese Präsentation startest die wir ungefähr 10-15 Minuten vor Beginn des Jahresrückblick gestartet hatten.
Da haben halt alle drauf geblickt und dann wurde insbesondere hat eben auch Constanze darauf geblickt die sagt ja neben mir
und die wurde dann natürlich nervös während dieser Timer eben anzeigte sowie rüber ziehen gleich und das hat dann dazu geführt dass sie eben mehrmals den Erdgeist gestupst hat und gesagt hat hier beeil dich beeil dich beeil dich beeil dich und
am Ende war der Türkei 10 Minuten zu früh zu Ende und das mit der das halt ich meinen sowas darf nicht passieren das ist.
Einfach ärgerlich und traurig und es tut mir leid für alle erfasst die da den dann da mit ihrer Arbeit entweder Eindruck vermittelt wurde.
Es gibt keine Zeit um um die zu würdigen da waren wir glaube ich alle am Ende sehr sehr zerknirscht.
Ja hier wäre vielleicht ein allgemeiner Verbesserungsvorschlag dass man alle Blüten mit einem generellen Zeit Counter ausrüstet der einfach das Ende des Lots anzeigt für alle immer.
Ja stimmt,
das stimmt nach was letztes Jahr mit dem Tod von Martin und mir also ich vertraue da tatsächlich lieber auf meinen eigenen Counter weil,
weil die weil es mir schon mehrfach passiert ist dass ich.
Quasi von der Bühne geprügelt wurde einmal als,
Karina und ich das Opening gemacht haben da hat der stage Manager oder die stage Manager Manager sind wie versehentlich ihre nur noch 5 Minuten Karte,
Vorsicht gehalten ist den Gang runter gegangen.
Und ich dachte oh mein Gott die rennt jetzt gerade los und will uns hier von der Bühne holen und wir haben nur noch fünf Minuten dabei hat sie einfach nur kann ja jedem mal passieren achtlos dieses Ding gehalten.
Und letztes Jahr bei dem Tod von Martin Forst und mir,
wollen wir auch dann in die von der Seite von der Bühne geschrieben mehr oder weniger weil irgendjemand den Fahrplan nicht korrekt lesen konnte,
wo nehme ich links Zeiten dran stehen und es ist auch ist auch ein Juwel lieber niemals persönliche
Vorwürfe indem der Fahrplan wenn man sich den Ausdruck ist halt danach die die die Größe der Felder richtet sich halt danach wie viel in den Feldern drin steht
und nicht wie viel Zeit sie einnehmen,
so dass hier halt der Eindruck war wir hätten nur in 40 Minuten Zielort und 100er oder halbe Stunde oder wo wärt ihr wieder in einer Dreiviertelstunde da von der Bühne geschrien und danach gabs dann eine halbe Stunde Pause die die kein Mensch nutzen insofern solche Sachen passieren
im Stress und ein eigener Counter erschien mir irgendwie die sinnvolle Gegenmaßnahme zu sein ist eben jetzt an dieser Stelle auch,
schiefgelaufen.
Weil eben wir hier ja also ich kann ich kann nicht mehr sagen als dass wir das wirklich wirklich leid tut und dass es nicht nur mir leid tut sondern eben auch allen die da oben saßen.
Dann haben wir uns ein bisschen ausgeruht und so da muss man ja auch mal irgendwie sich mal kurz das bisschen Zeit nehmen den Kongress irgendwie.
Auf sich wirken zu lassen denn am Tag drei war ja dann der Vortrag von von Thorsten und mir,
unter dem Titel du kannst alles hacken du darfst dich nur nicht erwischen lassen und weil Thorsten aus verschiedenen Gründen an dem Tag erst,
anreisen konnten wir natürlich uns dann an dem Tag getroffen weil ich den ganzen Tag mit der mit der Vorbereitung,
das Torx noch beschäftigt und der Tag war glaube ich ganz erfolgreich also,
hat mich mit Freude und Stolz gefühlt dass der Saal 1 da an voll war wir hatten aber natürlich auch die gute Chance
der David eine Stunde nach der Pause waren musste keiner dahin hetzen dabei nach der Pause von einer Stunde waren musste keiner da hinsetzen dahin hätten wir hatten also ein leichten strategischen Vorteil den den Saal zu füllen.
Nichtsdestotrotz freue ich mich natürlich über den darüber dass es auch dann geschafft haben ich glaube das waren ganz kurzweiliger Vortrag der war ja auch,
eingereicht als Foundation Stock also als
Einleitungen Stock der eben jetzt nicht in die in die Tiefe geht sondern so konzipiert es dass Ihnen alle möglichst verstehen und eben ein paar Basics vermittelt bekommen und außerdem war es unterhaltsam deklariert ich habe den Eindruck
dass wir beides ganz gut erreicht haben.
Ja das auf jeden Fall habe ich gesehen und kann man auf jeden Fall auf die Watchlist packen und sich mal anschauen weil
jeder einerseits sich Videos aus dem Netz entführt habt von entsprechenden Sicherheits
also ob sie fehlt also geht hier um
operacional Security wie sich wie sichere ich mein eigenes Handeln ab hier dargestellt anhand von bekloppten kriminellen die alles falsch machen und Jack das,
kann man sich natürlich auch wenn man nicht kriminell unterwegs ist hinter.
Am meisten freue ich mich aber natürlich über die YouTube Kommentare
also die Videos werden ja immer auf Media CCC de veröffentlicht und Media CCC de hat auch einen YouTube-Kanal das finde ich,
also die präferierte Variante die Videos zu schauen ist er verständlich bei Media CCC de aber.
Die richtig schönen Kommentare findet man nur bei bei YouTube Hase supergeil weil,
also YouTube Kommentare sind ja sowieso dass ich mal so dass das Blattgold
dass das Internet ne und weil ich habe heute nur mal Schluss kurz drüber gescrollt widerliche systemlinge scheiß Video Daumen runter
oder anscheinend macht der CCC jetzt Anleitungen für Cyberkriminelle schade zu was diese extrem linke Veranstaltung verkommen ist oder CCC Linksfaschisten Hetze Terror
Trainer weiß nicht genau warum Trainer aber dass das ist es natürlich auch.
Trainer.
Trainer ja weiß nicht genau.
YouTube Kommentare wirklich das Blattgold echt ein Traum für solche Kommentare mache ich dass ich da lacht mein Herz wenn ich wenn ich solche Kommentare sehe.
Und dann Gas.
Geil was ist schade zu was diese extreme linke Veranstaltung verkommen ist war das schon mal irgendwann mal anders eigentlich also habe ich jetzt irgendwie nicht so richtig dran erinnern.
Ja also die.
Ich meine wenn man den Vortrag gesehen hat dann weiß man ja auch mit welchen kleinen präparierten Schätzchen ich versucht habe genau solche Kommentare zu ködern insofern,
Seitenzahl bei diesen Leuten das verziehen.
Danke erst am Ende doch dass das wofür ich bevor ich tatsächlich am allermeisten aufgeregt war der da so dass der fährt mich am meisten
weil jetzt wird jeder darf einfach das wo ich am meisten Bammel vor hatte es war halt dass das letzte DJ-Set auf der Abschlussparty was er schon eine,
eine Herausforderungen aber auch Würdigung ist der natürlich messbar ich überhaupt nicht gewachsen bin.
Und da war ich echt froh dass Arne Bense sich davon mir früh hat Reitstall Anlassen dass wir das zusammen machen wären das ja auch zusammen eingereicht und das hat echt Spaß gemacht also.
Da gibt's auf jeden Fall gibt auf jeden Fall ein Bienchen von mir dafür für das Set das war die richtige Musik zum richtigen Zeitpunkt und war der perfekte Abschluss eines großartigen Kongresses.
Ist übrigens auch verlinkt wir haben das mal.
Bereitgestellt Link findet man in den shoutouts und da könnt ihr euch das wenn ihr das verpasst hat.
Bei der arbeit anhören zwischendurch waren wir noch weil ich noch ganz kurz beim beim Kohlenpott Folge 0.
Die müsste wenn Christian sich an seine Regeln hält gerade veröffentlicht worden sein oder heute noch veröffentlicht werden ich gucke mal ganz kurz.
Bist bist.
Veröffentlich da wunderbar dann der hat ja da immer genau Kohlenpott 0.
Ja diese Sache mit dem mit dem linksradikale Veranstaltung oder so das ist natürlich irgendwie so ein.
Haben ein Thema was gerade irgendwie die Leute bei diesem Kongress nicht nur nicht nur bei diesem Kongress sondern auch schon in den Jahren davor irgendwie beschäftigt hat.
Wir haben diesen CCC ja nun seit
35 Jahren und das ist ja ein Zeitraum wo ja immer betone als der TTC gegründet wurde war ich noch nicht mal in Planung das ist also ein relativ langer Zeitraum und.
Ein massives Wachstum der Veranstaltungen beobachten wir ja jetzt auch erst seit dem.
29c 3 als wir nach Hamburg gezogen sind und da gibt es natürlich eine.
Da gibt's einfach viele neue Personen die da irgendwie mit dazu kommen die vielleicht jetzt gar nicht so Didi,
wie viele Jahrzehnte Historie des CCC kennen und dann gibt es natürlich auch eine Reihe Leute die vielleicht aus guten Gründen.
Mit dem Wandel der Veranstaltung nicht so zufrieden sind dass es jetzt halt eben eine Veranstaltung mit 16 17.000 besuchenden und teilnehmenden ist während sie
beim 28.03 in Berlin halt irgendwie so mit dreieinhalb ungefähr agiert hat ne da,
gibt es viele viele Diskussionen und Reibereien darüber wie sich die Veranstaltungen.
In Zukunft zu entwickeln hätte und da gibt's dann natürlich auch Leute die z.b. daran Anschluss finden dass irgendjemand eine relativ große.
Antifa Flagge in den Elena Ex-Bereich der Glashalle gehängt hat um eben in.
An die sächsische Nachbarschaft des Veranstaltungsgelände ein entsprechendes Signal zu senden.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt nicht den Eindruck dass diese Veranstaltung sich irgendwo im Extrem linken Milieu abspielt aber sie hat natürlich ein gesundes Verständnis von.
Demokratie und gesundes Verständnis von Informationsfreiheit gesundes Verständnis davon was ein akzeptables,
Zusammenleben ist und ein gesundes Verständnis davon wo sich eine Demokratie lebhaft weiterentwickeln kann.
Und dann gibt's natürlich irgendwie so was weiß ich was was hat es gab es dieses Jahr irgendwas muss es ja auch immer geben worüber sich die Leute aufregen oder soll gar nicht heißen dass ich das unbedingt.
Gutheiße was da passiert ist ne ich finde es interessant welche Personengruppen dann was skandalisieren und es geht auch nie unter.
Der gesamte Kongress ist jetzt von Linksfaschisten unterwandert weil irgendwie ein Besucher.
Probleme hatte weil da irgendwo eine Deutschlandfahne drauf hatte was ich übrigens.
Zu diesem Fall mal sagen uns jetzt wirklich doof wenn da jemanden mit seinem ZDF Team internationale Erfolge feiert
und irgendein Wimpel hinaus Korea mitbringt wo eine kleine Deutschlandfahne drauf ist dann zeugt das nicht von der besonderen
Sensibilität für die Zähne und für das was
dieses Team da leistet und dessen was der seine Leidenschaft ist wenn da offenbaren der Situation herrscht dass dir dieses himpelchen da nicht aufstellen können,
wo eben ihr Team Name draufsteht und irgendwie steht aus welchem Herkunftsland dieses international erfolgreiche CTF Team stand ja das sind
tatsächlich unschöne Begebenheiten.
Aber ich glaube das ist weit davon entfernt dass wir jetzt hier eine gewaltbereite Veranstaltungen von von links versifften sind nur weil wir uns antidemokratische Kräfte verwehren.
Ja also das immer das Problem mit der Wahrnehmung das so Vorfälle dann halt gleich pauschalisiert werden das
geht sozusagen als Vorfall in Insa Größe der Veranstaltung eigentlich komplett unter und natürlich dann anders rezipiert ist aber nichtsdestotrotz auch durchaus ich will das auch noch mal
bekräftigen dass ich solche solche Aktion überhaupt nicht gut finde es gab einen zweiten Fall wo müssen.
Die Norweger die ihre Fahnen.
Ja schwedische Fahne und so weiter also irgendjemand es darum gerannt er so ein bisschen Problem mit Fahnen und Flaggen hatte die Argumentation kann ja vielleicht nachvollziehen aber natürlich so so eine eigenverantwortliche Maßnahme an der Stelle.
Nicht zu begrüßen das finde ich.
Nefel also doof ist doof und bringt auch keinen weiter ja
mein Fan haben wir in Disney wie so ein Ding sein ne meine meine meine Logbuch Netzpolitik Einhorn Standarte Fahne wo die auch geklaut.
Die Watte.
Ja von dir wahrscheinlich.
Jaja von wegen.
Ja es ist jetzt auch Missverständnisse nennt man irgendjemand hat ja auch noch so ein schöne Hoden Hut Burger Fotobox irgendwo auf.
Lieber richtig gut.
Ja er wurde aber auch von Leuten dann und wie komplett missverstanden ja die Propaganda und überhaupt also ja also manchen kann man es irgendwie aber auch nicht so richtig da liegen.
Ja so so also ich glaube ehrlich gesagt wenn du so kleiner Tipp wenn ihr merkt.
Dass ihr beim Kongress irgendwie aufeinmal so leichte Spannungen im Rücken habt so ja und ihr euch vielleicht über irgendwas aufregt oder so ja.
Kann sein dass dir geträumt wird.
Vermisse euch die Frage stellen ob ihr das nicht gerade vielleicht irgendwie ein bisschen zu verkrampft alles seht
und dass das hat noch nie jemanden weitergebracht und das war in dieser Szene auch noch nie so dass das jemand weiter gebracht hat und dieses dieses irgendwie
den Schweden und Norwegen die da seit Jahren irgendwie ihr ihr fehlt hier in hinhängen weil sie sich freuen dass sie dass sie aus diesem kleinen
bei unter bevölkerten Regionen ja auch mal auf der Veranstaltungen sind und da was vertreten wollen,
oder haben wir echt größere Probleme.
Und das finde ich affig wenn da Energie senken entstehen weil erstens Leute ihre Energie dafür aufwenden da solche fahren abzureißen und vor allem weil sie da den.
Seit Jahren angereisten Personen da den den Spaß wegnehmen ja also der Feind ist in der Regel immer noch außerhalb der Glashalle und es,
hilft sie ja sich darauf zu konzentrieren.
Tja was sie soll man noch mal so den ein oder anderen Ort lebend lobend erwähnen zusammen schwierig.
Ort Ort oder Vortrag.
Nee doch nicht Vorträge also vielleicht wenig zwei Sachen noch mal kurz die mir einfach an
besonders schön aufgefallen ich will's auch nicht zu sehr vertiefen weil ich ahne dass wir nächste Woche nerffreak froh dass sie noch mal in der epischen Breite ausrollen werden aber was wiederum sehr gelungen war weil dieser Kids place dieses Jahr trotz personeller
Veränderung deiner Organisation war wieder ein wunderbarer Ort und das Häuschen ich weiß nicht ob du immer die Gelegenheit hattest dir mal diese diese Installation dort anzuschauen.
Das Haus was da zusammengezimmert wurde.
Nananananana fehlen die Worte wie fantastisch das war also das war jetzt nicht nur wie so eine kleine Spielwiese sein also quasi sonst unserem Haus
gebaut worden wo wir vom Kaufmannsladen Apotheke Badezimmer Schlafzimmer alles irgendwie drin war wunderbar gearbeitet also fantastisch was kann ich wer dafür verantwortlich war aber das war auf jeden Fall,
super und mein persönliches Highlight war die Chaos Post was auch Post bekommen.
Ich habe auch Post bekommen ja vielen Dank an dieser Stelle war bei einigen ohne Absender dann damit hier noch mal der herzliche Dank für die Post.
Genau wird wenn ich weiß wovon wir reden Kauspass Bahrain.
Tatsächlich wohl schon letztes Jahr da war aber noch nicht diese Sichtbarkeit erlangt hatte man konnte also vorgefertigte Postkarten ausfüllen an eine beliebige Person auf dem Kongress adressieren mehr oder weniger genau.
Und warf sie sodann in einen von zwei Briefkästen die irgendwo rum standen und dann haben freiwillige die einfach Spaß hatten diese Herausforderung anzunehmen
diese die Briefkästen geleert und Sicht Hand damit beschäftigt diese Postkarten dem Empfänger zuzustellen,
was hat FIFA 17 1000 Leuten im Haus Herausforderung ist weil er steht da halt teilweise nicht mehr drauf als und Nickname
so dann muss halt erstmal los und irgendwie rausfinden okay wer könnte das sein wo könnte diese Person sein wo können sie sich generell aufhalten wo es in diesem Moment erzählt
IP und keine Ahnung ob ich alles erreicht hat was mir zugesendet wurde aber
wann ist nach zwei Karten schon ziemlich beeindruckt vor man merkt wo man aufgegriffen wird
und ja ich habe das viele schöne Geschichten gehört von anderen Leuten denen auch lange überfällige Danksagung zuteil wurden und das fand ich einen sehr schönen Mechanismus sehe diesen Kongress erheblich
aufgewertet hat offensichtlich uns eine eine eine Inspiration von Burning Man aus den USA wo sowas wohl schon seit längerem gibt.
Was gibt's noch also das Intro video.
Oh das Auto das war irre wer bitte wer.
Friedrich Brückner.
Dachte mir schon.
Ja klar also der hat ist ja in langjähriger Freund von mir,
und ist seit der hat mir auch damals schon als Karina und ich das Opening gemacht haben beim 32 C3.
Hatte er das Video beigesteuert dass dass das Audio opening Animation.
Was auch schon ganz teurer.
Da war das weil Roland und Frederick die beiden sind Brüder dir beim 32 auch das Design gemacht und dann habe ich irgendwie.
Hatten wir so gesprochen und dann habe ich gesagt er sag mal wie sieht's denn aus hab.
Irgendwie das so ein Animation wenigstens zu machen oder so wenn er schon nicht den kompletten Kongress designt was wir dieses Jahr
wie Darsteller gemacht hat die auch den 33c 3 gemacht hat übrigens auch denke ich wieder ein echt schönes Ding mal rumgekommen.
Und dann der Deal mit mit Frederik ist im Prinzip du machst oder ihr macht er.
Ich habe leider nicht genau die Liste von seinen Kumpels die da noch mitgemacht haben aber der Deal ist immer ihr macht das Video worauf ihr Bock habt.
Und wir Funken nicht rein ja also das ist das ist gerade der dir das Lied,
wie man eine Video aussieht Dustin Halbprofi ist ne das sind nicht irgendwie Leute die die sowas mal spaßeshalber machen oder nicht schon spaßeshalber aber die machen halt im Prinzip beruflich den ganzen Tag nichts anderes als 3D Animationen dass sie Meier
denke ich schon auch an der Qualität und müssen aber natürlich normalerweise für Kunden arbeiten.
Die dann am Anfang eine geile Idee kriegen und dann wieder so ist ne im weiteren Verlauf da sehr viele Änderungswünsche haben bis am Ende ein Ergebnis steht und unser dir das immer so.
Und wir sagen am Ende artig Danke und entsprechend ist halt dann auch da die Qualität so seid danke.
Ich denke das ist ja bin ich habe ich mich sehr sehr drüber gefreut und ich glaube ist auch echt gut abgegangen als Rex und Rufus halt das Opening gemacht haben.
Wo diese Animation ja dann eben gezeigt wurde das hat schon hat abgeräumt ja.
Ja auf jeden Fall kannst ganz ganz tolles Ding.
Na wenn wir jetzt schon in den ISA mal in den Details sind ja und jetzt hier persönlich danken können nadella herzlichen Dank für alles was sie ist immer wirklich ein
ein Sonnenschein wie sie auch wirklich nicht eher Ruhe gibt als dass alle alle Logos haben die Sie brauchen.
Supergeil übrigens auch bleeptrack hier zu erwähnen die den Logo Generator gemacht hat.
Dieses ich weiß ob das gesehen hast das ist das unter 35 C3. Lieb.
Manchmal konnte sich online quasi so ein random Design auf Basis auf Grundlage des Standarddesign das 35 C3 für seine Gruppe machen davon Ampel auch viele Leute.
Total viele in ihren Torx und so dass das Ding hat immer zufällig ein anderes in der andere Leiterbahnen gezeichnet und so richtig cool.
Ja richtig cool vor allem fand ich das insofern toll als dass das.
Schon verdammt nah an mein bisheriges Lieblingsdesign eines Kongresses rankam hat mich total beeindruckt hat Bayer 29 C3 weil das ja nicht nur
eine Gestaltung war waren auch eine Gestaltung in der Animation ne also man ändert sich da gab's da so JavaScript-Code der dann irgendwie
Text auf Webseiten also diese ganzen Satzzeichen immer so durch rotiert hat und Zeichen ersetzt hat in diesem in diesem Style das fand ich super intelligent und super cool
und dieses Jahr ist das Logo auch wieder sehr weite Wege gegangen und ich denke das
muss auch ein bisschen die Zukunft sein das Logodesign also man geht nicht nur darum irgendwie mein hübsches Ding zu erzeugen was ich ganz gut macht auf dem Poster oder auf dem Shirt das muss halt.
So verspielt sein dass man eben möglich
bereit zur Anwendung bringen kann in den unterschiedlichsten Kontexten und daneben aber auch auf eine bestimmte Art und weis da ist eben durch solche Generatoren durch Open Source oder was auch immer möglichst vielen zugänglich ist im Vorfeld um dir Kredit
Kreativität der allgemeinen da noch mehr Futter zu geben.
Ja das hat glaube ich hier gut geklappt eine einen einen großen Spaß hatten wir übrigens auch das war ich glaube kann man sagen,
das ging auf eine Idee von Macke zurück dass wir noch diese 42 C3 schwarz gemacht haben.
42 C3 also sie wie ihr ja alle,
wurde ja dann 2025 der ber eröffnet und seit der Eröffnung des BER ist ja eben auch Zeitreisen möglich
und das ist natürlich immer ein bisschen verwirrend aber waren eben einige Zeitreisende dann dort vom 42 C3 die den,
letzten Kongress ohne massiver voll Überwachung,
noch einmal besuchen wollten und das hat natürlich zu einigen Verwirrungen gefühlt und für mich jetzt irgendwie zu dem Problem dass ich dahin steuern muss das der 42 C3 unter dem Motto time travel.
Is not a crime stattfindet mal schauen schauen ob wir das hinkriegen InDesign haben wir auf jeden Fall schon.
King es.
Stelle das dürften das türkische strategischer Vorsprung sein.
Ja also da gab es sowieso einige Konfusion wir sind auch einige 36 C3 Bettchen und gekauft und scheint sich das schon so bisschen Zeit ich durcheinander Mäander zu haben.
Na gut.
Genau dann ja dann gab es ja auch ein
ein Spaß der sich lange gehalten hat war ja das dann manchmal liebt man ja dann doch das Internet wenn ich das richtig rekonstruiere.
Hat der Raven irgendwie.
Irgendwelche AOT Sachen irgendwo bei Maus oder bestellt oder sowas und das Ganze getwittert unter irgendwie Einkauf für den 35 C3 everything is the target woraufhin.
Bis zu den bis zu den Twitter Journalisten alle darauf sprangen und dachten dass wir jetzt das Motto.
Und das fand ich natürlich sehr amüsant und wie das so ist wenn sich sowas einmal fest fährt
und ist ein Hashtag gibt
dann gehen natürlich auch Leute her und entwickeln da die entsprechenden Designs für sodass ich dann am Ende noch ein T-Shirt bekommen habe mit dem alternativ sitzdesign 35 C3 everything is the target mit dem eben auch alle möglichen Leute darum Randen.
Diese solche solche Spielereien sind einfach schön und machen Spaß und das.
Merda.
Jetzt erst scheiße jetzt habe ich super schon so in den Details habe jetzt jetzt wird mir warm und kalt dass ich Angst habe dass ich natürlich jetzt Leute vergesse den wir zu danken haben.
Das muss jetzt muss auch nicht unser letzter Beitrag gewesen sein zum 35 C3 vielleicht gehen wir jetzt auch noch mal auf die talks
ein bisschen ein was wir noch so an Vorträgen empfehlen können
denn erfahrungsgemäß zieht sich der Kongress ja dann im Nachgang ohnehin für die alle Beteiligten und vor allem für die unbeteiligten noch ein paar Wochen,
hin und denkt da wird auch noch sehr viel im Nachgang hochkommen und vielleicht der ein oder andere Gesprächsbedarf noch mal entstehen denk im Wesentlichen,
habe jetzt erst mal zusammengefasst was hier an ich das wichtigste ist festzustellen und Rest fand statt Kongress war gut und sehr guter sehr sehr guter Kongress meiner Meinung nach wieder eine totale Höchstleistung
mein Dank geht vor allem an alle die hier organisatorisch mit gewerkelt haben dieser Kongress ging bei manchen Teams,
sehen die Grenzen also insbesondere hier die SM die Orga die hatte es irgendwie mit.
390 verschiedenen Gruppen zu tun die in irgendeiner Form auf diesem Kongress einen Platz gefunden haben,
Bedürfnisse hatten zugeteilt werden mussten etc 390 also ist eine Zahl und ich finde es toll auch das und gerade im Hinblick auf diese Debatte mit ist der Kongress zu groß geworden.
Der Kongress ist ist das was er ist.
Und er hat einfach in den Raum zu finden den die Leute suchen.
Und deswegen ist der Kongress so auch in Ordnung wie er ist es es es ja immer.
Immer so diese Debatte mit wie groß kann irgendwas werden wie groß soll irgendwas werden ist es dann noch so wie früher als Hitler Pipi,
Janni ist nicht so wie früher was anderes aber die Zeiten haben sich auch geändert die Bedürfnis haben sich geändert die Zähne hat sich geändert die Nachfrage ist größer dieser Kongress war wieder einmal ein sehr gutes Beispiel dafür.
Was aus diesem Kongress in der Zukunft noch werden kann was ich jetzt in Ansätzen schon zeigt nämlich einen.
Breiter gesellschaftlicher Diskurs der sich nicht nur in der Themen Breite der Vorträge niederschlägt sein der sich auch einfach in der,
Breite der Teilnehmer
wo die Leute alle herkommen was deren Kontexte Normalitäten sind ja schlägt wir sind halt schon lange weit über diesen Hacker Kongress Ding eigentlich hinaus.
Wo das trotzdem irgendwo noch ist der Club und der Kongress in seiner ursprünglichen dann besprechen Zuschnitt hat definiert was das Herz dieser Veranstaltung ist.
Tara und das und das ist auch nach wie vor da und ich finde es ist ein sehr starkes Element und drückt sich auch immer noch,
und immer mehr in in in in in vielfältigen Dingen aus oder wir organisiert es dieses ganze engelsystem dieser Spaß den die Leute daran haben
diese Bereitschaft auf Augenhöhe miteinander zu kommunizieren und und und und Leute danach zu bewerten was.
Sie tun ja und was sie was sie konkret machen und nicht wie sie aussehen wo sie herkommen ca,
dass das ist so prophetische die Saga Ethik mal rein geschrieben worden als Anerkenntnis aus den,
der Beobachtung dieser Szene in den 60er 70er und 80er Jahren und ich finde das gilt immer noch.
Und ich habe mit so vielen Leuten gesprochen.
Die das erste Mal auf diesem Kongress fahren ich habe nicht nur mit ihm gesprochen hab teilweise bin ich stundenlang mit Leuten über diesen Kongress gelaufen ist erste Mal da waren weil ich mich irgendwie super verstanden habe und,
tolle Gespräche geführt hatte gute Atmo da waren gerade die Reaktion der Erstbesucher fand ich extrem ermutigender Hinsicht weil dir das auch sofort gespürt habe,
selber sofort gemerkt haben komm rein und auf einmal ist man umgeben von seiner weichen Blase.
Wo man einerseits halten weitgehend arschlochfreie Zone vorfindet und auch einfach,
sofort das Gefühl hat man kann in jeder kloschlange irgendwie auf einem höheren intellektuellen Level in irgendein Thema einsteigen als Bundestag debattiert wird.
Das stimmt mich alles sehr positiv und ich denke da ist der Kongress auf dem richtigen Weg die Größe.
Hat natürlich Nachteile klar man muss weit laufen und es schwierig und man weiß dann immer nicht wo ist und so aber erstens finden sich für viele dieser Sachen dann meistens auch immer ganz pfiffige Lösung.
Wird die Zeit und andererseits sind die Vorteile halt auch offenbar ne Kongresse zu international Camp im Winter geworden ist das Wintercamp
was bloß nicht nur in der Halle gesagt hat es waren auch außerhalb der Halle also allein das Angebot mit dem Wohnwagen Parkplatz ist ja auch massiv an.
Also immer angeschaut hast aber da waren irgendwie 230 Wohnwagen standen da irgendwie in das gesamte Gelände war
Fall also benutzen im Winter nicht nur das Messegelände mittlerweile schon zu nahezu 100% aus zu einem Hort das Außengelände das muss erstmal einer nachmachen fertig einfach mind-blowing.
Man muss natürlich,
sehen dass es zunehmend schwieriger wird auf die Leute die dort sind den.
Vom CCC bereitgestellten Teil mit dem was Menschen die dort hinkommen und aufbauen
zu da die beiden Sachen zu unterscheiden oder dahinter den Unterschied zu sehen für mich ein sehr häufiger häufig zu hören der Kritikpunkt ist das programm habe sich verändert das einfach nicht war also der die Aufteilung
das Programm sehr prozentual wie viel IT security wie viel politics wie viel Kunst wie viel,
wie viel Resilienz oder eben den andere oder andere Gast trägst,
seit Jahren marginal unverändert ja da ist es mag sein dass dann eine halbe Stunde mehr in Security landet oder meine halbe Stunde mehr in ins 1 oder so aber die die Aufteilung des Programmes ist.
Unverändert.
Was hinzukommt ist dass immer mehr sämtliche insbesonder bei diesem Kongressen inkomplette weitere Halle ist Emily Fläche dazukommt und wo,
Menschen ihre eigenen Dinge hochziehen Work-Shop Programme eigene Bühnen die Werkhaus West und so quasi auch Angebote.
Machen auf dem Kongress die natürlich jetzt jemand dir darum läuft schwer zu unterscheiden sind im Sinne von AOK dass es hier hier bin ich jetzt auf der Bühne von Chaos West die haben ihr eigenes Programm gemacht und ich bin nicht auf einer der Content Bühnen,
das Kongress.
Da sehe ich primär einfach die Herausforderung das auch in Zukunft so zu zeigen oder bei der Orientierung zu helfen sodass,
ich meinte selbstverständlich gibt's dann gibt's da es Handys die auch großes Handys machen die wo kein einziger Lötkolben liegt wo Hecking im,
technischen Sinne.
Eine untergeordnete Rolle spielt wird aber auch andere sms die nichts anderes machen ja oder die des ZDF Team was dann Capture the Flag veranstalteten ich habe so ein bisschen hinein und das,
so insbesondere jetzt mal.
Kern Zähne Hacker ja dann sagen er hier ist irgendwie so viel Zeug was ich von anderen Hacker Veranstaltungen nicht kenne.
Dass ich mich jetzt zu dem Eindruck.
Verleitet fühle es handele sich jetzt hier um eine Republica oder sonst was aber trotzdem noch zum zdf Team gehen die in in den in den ZDF Bewertungen irgendwie so mit den besten ZDF,
weltweit ausrichten ja du hast halt auch Kids Base obendrüber den du vielleicht woanders in der vom Licht findest heißt aber nicht dass ich dir Focus,
der Veranstaltung geändert hätte oder dass die Veranstaltung jetzt an einem Punkt wäre wo der Security Anteil den wir dort haben in Workshops intorq.
In challenges heißt die SDR Challenge vom Münchner CCC ne da ist das CTF das dass diese ganze Menge Security so gering wäre.
Dass irgendein Mensch sie vollständig passen könnte ja das heißt da gibt's immer noch so viel Programm und so viel Auswahl in den technischen Bereichen des ist immer noch dein Kopf springt.
Es gibt eben nur noch dazu in den ist hamleys viele weitere Angebote aber der Kongress selber was die quasi die Mischung des Kongresses ist.
Ist eigentlich inhaltlich seid seit jeher oder seit seit vielen vielen Jahren unverändert.
Also in seiner in seiner Aufteilung in die einzelnen Ressorts.
Themengebiet höher.
Ist aber thematisch schon in die Breite gegangen dass das ist auch gut so und müssen wir auch machen
finde das eigentlich Viertel vollkommen richtig gewisser Hinsicht hat der Kongress und bisschen das ähnliche Problem wie das Edinburgh Festival ich weiß nicht ob dir das was sagt.
Nee aber das ist mir jetzt auch echt ein bisschen sehr weit aber erzähl mir jetzt auch noch vom Edinburgh.
Na ja das ist schon so eine veranstalten die man eigentlich mal gehört haben sollte handelt sich nämlich eigentlich um die Größe Kultur kulturelle Festival Europas.
Findet jedes Jahr in edinboro statt ganzen September lang ist diese Stadt mehr oder weniger komplett
eingenommen von diesem Festival war aber ursprünglich halt mal eine
Veranstaltung die sich quasi nur sehen Haie Arzt zugewendet hat da gabs ein bisschen Military Tattoo und Konzerte und Theater und so weiter und war mehr oder weniger so ein bisschen von oben herab organisiert und mit der Zeit hat sich diesem Edinburgh Festival
dann von unten eine gegen organisiertes oder dazu organisiert es ist nicht für dich eine Anti Veranstaltung ist es mehr so ein wir aber jetzt auch Veranstaltung gewesen
das Fringe Festival ja also wurde die Fransen der Rand der Gesellschaft sozusagen auch seinen Beitrag machen will
ist dann somit aufgekommen und mittlerweile
ist das eine Veranstaltungshaus mit dem Essen Büro Festival versteht man sowohl eben das alte traditionelle Programm plus eben das Fringe Festival.
Für sich genommen noch mal viel viel viel größer ist als alle und was letztlich dazu führte Cindy in jeder Kneipe jeden Kaffee überall wo mehr als vier Leute unterkommen können
Programm angeboten wird und die ganze Stadt
leuchtet sozusagen in seiner Gesamtheit und so ein bisschen nehme ich auch den Kongress war ja also ja wir haben mir das Kernprogramm des eigentlichen Chaos Communication Congress das Angebot die Organisation und alles aber es lebt halt auch,
von dem was alle anderen dazu beitragen und natürlich muss man dann
schauen okay wenn man jetzt eine Aussage über den Kongress macht im Sinne von wie er früher war ja dann darf man sich das auch nur nur nur Äpfel mit Äpfel vergleichen aber es kommt halt jetzt was neues dazu
das hatten gewissen dynamischen lauf das muss begleitet und beobachtet werden aber grundsätzlich.
Läuft das alles in die richtige Richtung und der Kongress wird halt insgesamt eine vielfältige Ort wo viele sich
ausdrücken können und verwirklichen können die vielleicht vorher so noch gar nicht für sich eine Lücke gesehen haben und das Finja auch total super weil es war schon immer eine der wichtigsten Aufgaben die.
Ja ja also der Vergleich ist sehr schön da gesellt sich viel hin und da werden die wenn die richtigen Leute hingeführt und die richtigen Leute fühlen sich da wohl.
Bin aber muss ich persönlich muss sagen ich stehe dem nicht gänzlich und kritisch gegenüber also ich.
Ich finde das Fringe Festival was ich in sehr schöne Bezeichnung für die ist Emily Hallen halte finde ich großartig ich bin immer dass es halt auch das was ein
wenn man jetzt in der Organisation der Veranstaltungen bisschen involviert ist am meisten irgendwie belohnt ja nehme ich zusehen krass,
wir haben hier nämlich nur einen einen Kristallisationspunkt geschaffen ja das war woran wir die ganze Zeit gearbeitet haben in unserem Team ne sei es jetzt.
Contentteam oder oder Designteam oder merge Team oder was weiß ich die Projektleitung liegen die ganzen Teams haben alle irgendwie ihren Blick auf diese Veranstaltung der eben maximal,
ihre Arbeitsbereiche und die mit denen sie interface and und ein Gehirn was 24 Stunden in die Welt blickt.
Umfassen kann und für alle geht's dann eben an der Eröffnung oder während das entsteht,
große große Überraschung für sie so krasser Scheiß was haben die denn jetzt hier auf Gefahren ja,
oh das ist natürlich der der belohnen ist Detail ich sehe das aber schon so dass die Veranstaltung ihren Kern ganz offensichtlich.
Mehr schärfen muss weil die wie ich rieche trotzdem überzeugt.
Der ist handelt sich um eine Fehlwahrnehmung ja also arbeitest handelt sich deshalb um eine Fee Wahrnehmung weil wir die.
Verschobene Wahrnehmung offenbar irgendwie unterstützen oder herbeiführen na also ich sage nicht,
dass jemand der jetzt dahingegangen ist und Schwierigkeiten hatte das Security Angebot zu finden selber schuld ist.
Ich sage wir haben offenbar eine Ansprache an die Menschen,
erreicht wo sie mehr Hilfe brauchen die Dinge zu finden das ist natürlich für jemanden der irgendwie in dieser Veranstaltung viel drin ist total.
Schwer nachvollziehbar oder schwer vorstellbar wie das Ding jetzt auf jemanden wirkt der,
was was ich vielleicht nicht in die Orga eingebunden ist wir haben eben viele viele tausend Leute die da sind und dann morgens reinkommt und steht in dieser Bahnhofshalle da ja und dann versteckt sich irgendwo in Halle 7
ich weiß es gibt keine halle7 deswegen nicht jetzt so versteckt sich jetzt irgendwie der fette Security Vortrag
Headliner ja und da muss man irgendwie dorthin finden und dann muss man eben die online finde ich habe versucht dem entgegenzuwirken insbesondere indem auf den auf den Tickets steht irgendwie groß drauf,
wo online die Sachen zu finden sind ich bin auch einer der eine der Person die hauptsächlich daran schuld ist dass es keinen ausgedruckten Plan,
weil ich das für Müllhalde und für Umweltbelastung und Quatsch aber ich,
natalist nagt an mir das wahrscheinlich so etwas bei dieser Größe der Veranstaltung wahrscheinlich unvermeidbar ist den Leuten an die Hand zu geben damit sie
eine Orientierung finden und wenn ich mir jetzt irgendwie sagen wir mal so einen alten Hacker Haudegen vorstelle der da,
vorne reinkommt und nicht weiß nicht welche Richtung er gehen muss.
Oder landet auf einmal im kids.ch oder über den Nerv in der falschen ist Emily Halle und Wirtin vom Elektro Roller umgefahren und als nächstes
so dann kann ich mir vorstellen wieder wie deine Orientierungslosigkeit und ohne Frustration einsetzt.
Na ja gut also also wenn alter Hacker Haudegen nicht in der Lage ist irgendwie retrusion Programm abzurufen dann glaube ich der Name dann auch schon vollkommen fehl am Platze.
Es ist aber jetzt hier eine harte das kann jetzt auch als ne harte.
Ja ich dir übersetze ich finde auch diese komischerweise höre ich.
Immer wenn es um solche Sachen geht immer Security als Beispiel wo ich auch sagen muss.
Der Kongress ist keine Security Veranstaltung ja das ist kein security event das war der Uni sonderkongress war immer das was er jetzt ist ein breiter.
Aufgestellter gesellschaftlicher Diskurs in dem security
eine Rolle spielt aber beileibe nicht die einzige Rolle und auch nicht die wichtigste Rolle sondern am wichtigsten ist da gar nichts.
Wann bist du denn das alles und von daher sehe ich da wenig Probleme und.
Na da würde ich aber schon irgendwie mal reingrätschen wollen wo worüber sich die Leute.
Wundern oder ärgern ist je nachdem wie stark da ihre Wahrnehmung emotionalen Reaktionen sind.
Ist das hier auf einem Hacker Kongress sind und ein Hacker Kongress,
ist primär dadurch gekennzeichnet dass dort Hacker sind das ist in bei,
17000 Leuten aus unterschiedlichsten kulturellen Bereichen nicht bei allen 17.000 der Fall.
Das mag jetzt vielleicht für die ein oder andere Person ein bisschen despektierlich klingen aber es gibt eben bestimmte Dinge die sind hacking und es gibt bestimmte Dinge die sind.
Auch sehr interessant.
Und alles davon haben wir hier vertreten und da ist natürlich Security ein Bereich der für die meisten Hacker oder Technik eben zum Kernbereich dessen gehört was hacking
ist und da finde ich das völlig klar dass die sagen ich bin auf einer Hacker Veranstaltung meine Erwartung ist ich will nen ordentlichen CTF sehen
haben wir geliefert ich will ein paar geile technische challenges sehen wurde in den es hamleys geliefert ich will selbstverständlich anspruchsvolle und zwar mitunter die besten Security Speaker die diese Welt zu bieten hat,
in diesem Jahr auf dieser Bühne sehen haben wir geliefert das hat überhaupt nichts damit zu tun dass diese Menschen die wie ein eingeschränktes Weltbild hätten sondern dass die eine legitime Erwartung an eine Hacker Veranstaltung haben und diese legitime Erwartung
haben wir denken bin ich mir ganz sicher übererfüllt und mein Problem sehe ich maximal oder das Problem sehe ich maximal dort dass wir den Menschen eben mehr,
helfen müssen ihre Interessen dazu finden und dass sie da würde ich gar nicht anfangen irgendwie alte Hecke Haudegen zu beleidigen oder so ich sehe eher das Problem tatsächlich wenn,
eine Kritik geäußert wird wie Security spielt keine Rolle mehr oder sowas dass man die Erde dann nehme ich die erstmal war und schaue okay faktisch ist nicht richtig.
Weil hat eine große Rolle gespielt von Wahlen über Gesundheitsdaten,
über wen Erkennung haben wir wieder.
Irgendwie mit die wichtigsten Torx in diesem Themenbereich technisch sauber auf unseren Bühnen gehabt Hardware hacking Wallet Fell und was nicht alles ja also wirklich feinstes feinstes.
Katja allprint alt Schwein feinstes Hack vom Fachmann.
Hatten wir in der Auslage ja und wenn jetzt natürlich die Leute sagen das gab's hier nicht das gab's da nicht und das habe ich nicht wahrgenommen dann ist das Problem den wir uns widmen müssen und dadurch sich ganz klar.
Ja also verstehe dein. Bei mir ist der Begriff Hacker halt
generell weiter gefasst für mich ist es halt state of mind Zeit eine Art und Weise wie man auf diese Welt schaut und.
Von daher denke ich dass das auch den Großteil der Teilnehmer mit ein.
So dann wollen wir jetzt überhaupt noch in die Torx gehen weil ich sehe du bist doch wisse Metall der Kongress Sache gegangen wollen wir noch ein bisschen Torx empfehlen oder wollen wir uns das aufbewahrt.
Ja niemals.
Okay dann mal kurz in Durchblick mit dem disclaimer.
Werden auch noch nicht alle gesehen wie immer werden wir die Vorträge über das Jahr verteilt auf würdigen weil,
Kongress Vorträge nicht selten die Eigenschaft haben zu reifen und über das Jahr noch sehr viel wichtiger zu werden.
Insofern ist es jetzt eine Gemeinde teils persönliche Auswahl mit Schwerpunkt natürlich auch auf die,
Interessen der vermuteten Interessen der Leute die ihr zuhören nämlich Politik.
Am Anfang würde ich gerne mit dem Vortrag von Frank Rieger Hacker Ethik eine Einführung.
Und zwar deshalb weil ich weiß nicht genau wie oft,
ich jetzt auch schon ewig mein Vortrag über die Hacker Ethik gehalten habe bestimmt 4-5 Mal und ich bin ja auch eigentlich jemand der dem diese Hacker Ethik und nur tradiert wurde,
Hotel sich da irgendwie im Laufe seines Lebens ein paar Gedanken zu gemacht hat und ich fand das besonders großartig wie.
Die Frank auf diese Sachen blickt welche Vergleiche Erfahrungen und Situationen er dann noch mal.
Angeführt hat um im auch zu zeigen dass diese e.t. das hast du ja gerade auch gesagt eben sehr viel mehr ist als als das was da jetzt.
In detail in den Zeilen steht sondern das Leben sehr viel darüber hinauswächst fand ich einen sehr großartigen Vortrag vor allem weil Frank ja inzwischen.
Nur noch so gut wie frei spricht zu wissen sein echt guten Vorträgen und das kann man sich auf jeden Fall.
Mal reinziehen das natürlich ein Foundation Stock,
Tricks mit schöner Situation welcher Sache die Hacker Ethik wird radiert Frank hat sie ja auch nicht geschrieben ja
der hat sie auch tradiert bekommen primär von war Holland und da gibt's diese schöne Situation wo Frank dann sagt ja und diesen Satz hat war auch hinzugefügt und außen aus dem Publikum ruft,
nein das war ich wo was ich auch einfach eine sehr sehr schöne gelebte Situation fand
das daneben
einfacher Frank live aus dem Publikum korrigiert wird von einem der Mitautoren der Hacker Ethik einfach mal sitzen und
zeigt ja auch dass der Kongress eben seinen Kern doch sehr bewahrt hat peinlich natürlich für Frank.
Details ja manches wird vielleicht zu einfach wow Zuge
textet leider konnte bevor wir mit wow richtig in den wie war das eigentlich früher genau Diskurs gehen wollten das hatten wir ja irgendwann mal geplant leider.
Zaz.
War er dann irgendwie kurzfristig ab LEBIG das hat uns ja sehr geärgert von daher haben wir da ein Loch noch zu füllen.
Dann war ein Kollege von dir auf der Bühne sage ich mal kann man so sagen oder.
Bierhalter alter Hacker Legende.
Genau und auch ein ehemaliger Gast schon hier bei Logbuch Netzpolitik als wir nämlich über die ganze pc-wahl Sache Gesprächen haben Martin tschirsich chillig hat sich,
Hörgeschädigte hat ja hat sich mal diese ganze Gesundheitsdaten Zähne genauer angeschaut nicht
nur aber zum Start vor allem mit
Vivi App die ja hier auch schon in der Diskussion war aber auch diverse andere Anbieter sprich er hat sich mal ganz genau angeschaut wie sicher sind denn eigentlich diese ganzen Systeme die Versprechen deine Gesundheitsdaten in der Cloud oder wo auch immer vorzuhalten um daneben einen möglichst eleganten Fluss dieser Informationen zu beteiligten Ärzten zu organisieren
naja ist Spoiler das mal Katastrophe.
Katastrophe und was ich was ich an dem dem Vortrag zur spannt auch finde er hat er auch quasi historisch betrachtet wie viel Daten schon verloren gehen er hat gesehen.
Dass einige Unternehmen ihr quasi einpreisen dass sie bis zu soundsoviele Daten pro Jahr verlieren werden und hat dann einfach mal extra poliert und hat gesagt 2050 war das glaube ich.
Sind dann einfach alle Daten öffentlich ja wenn jede wenn jedes Jahr soundsoviel Daten verloren werden und und und das quasi schon in den Invest
Investitionen mit eingepreist wird ja die haben quasi schon die Entschädigungszahlungen im Budget
ja dann hat kann er halt einfach davon extrapolieren wie es ausgeht das heißt Martin der technischer sowieso brillante Nase hat so Sachen zu finden hat hier auch noch mal den den Vortrag,
um eben auch für diese diese gesamte metaperspektive hervorragend angereichert dass es das sind eben die Vorträge die man beim Kongress,
haben will die man da sehen in grossarl.
Noujoum der einen Vortrag gehalten hat Minecraft die Netzpolitik der AFD im Bundestag da ist es auch feierlich richtig YouTube Kommentare anzuschauen,
kannst ja vorstellen ne das ist war ja vorhersehbar was da für ein Feedback kommen würde bei dir muss ich mich bei ihr muss ich mich aber auch persönlich noch mal entschuldigen weil sie hat
den sie hat ja auch geheiratet also sie hat den den Tod von Thorsten und mir angekündigt,
und da gab es diese echt unschöne Situationen für sie irgendwie unschöne Situation sie hat bei der Ankündigung unseres Torx.
Also gesagt meldet euch mal wer schon mal irgendwo eine Sicherheitslücke gefunden hat und dann nicht wusste was er damit machen sollte er und es haben sich halt ein paar Leute oder was haben sich viele Leute im Publikum gemeldet Thorsten und ich aber nicht.
Ja weil unser Ford Verkehr davon handelte von obseques und wir gehen doch nichts,
dann sagte sie als nächstes Jahr wer hatte wer würde denn gerne meine Sicherheitslücke finden und Horst und ich haben uns gemeldet so ja würde uns echt mal interessieren würde
lädst nächstes sagt aber sie hat uns nicht gesehen weil sie vor anstatt wenn das nächste sagte sie dann so ja hier Linus und Thorsten haben waren an den Bundestagswahl,
beteiligt und wir beide du so nein,
Schwalbe wir würden das Handy zu gehen und damit haben wir sie aber leider total aus dem Konzept gebracht und weil sie hat irgendwer das letzte womit sie gerechnet hat ist dass wir auf einmal irgendwie so.
Ein nicht zu leugnen des Feature leugnen würden und sie war dann da haben wir glaube ich echt dass das tat mir richtig leid wenn sie jetzt hat ok,
nein echt nicht okay dann laber ich jetzt hier totalen Unsinn war total verunsichert hat noch die Folge empfohlen wo.
Thorsten Martin und ich davon berichtet haben und ja dass das tat mir echt leid und auf eine gewisse Weise kann sie einem auch leid tun für die Kommentare die sie jetzt mit ihrem Talk,
meinte trefft ihr nicht besiegt der AFD im Bundestag bekommen hat ich hoffe.
Die sind sind mittlerweile deaktiviert.
Aber nachgeschaut ist alles schon ausgeschaltet kann man sich in etwa ausmalen.
Ja also das ist nee das ist aber das.
Dabei muss ich sagen hat sie das Thema doch sehr ausgeglichen präsentiert ja also worum ging es ging darum.
Ein Einblick zu erhalten in die Bundestags Arbeit der netzpolitische zuständigen Menschen der afd-fraktion und.
Tatsächlich hatte sie ja auch Gutes zu berichten also sie meinte es
jetzt nicht nur die totalen Schreihals Nazis die im Wesentlichen darauf aus sind den Diskurs im Bundestag zu zerrütten sondern es gibt auch noch so ein paar Nasen,
die dich zum ist augenscheinlich an ja ein bestimmte Verhaltenserwartungen halten und,
im Kontext des üblichen Umgangs im Bundestag agieren da gehören sie ihrer Aussage nach,
die Leute dazu die so vergeblich
König Politik sich zuständig gefühlt haben eine Person ist allerdings mittlerweile aus der afd-fraktion auch wieder ausgetreten all diese Hintergründe wie das zu bewerten ist finden sich in ihrem Vortrag.
Ja der war auf jeden Fall auch ein schöner dann Verhalten bei Hausdurchsuchung ist natürlich.
Klar musste musste vertreten sein auf dem Kongress wo es
in dem Jahr zwei Hausdurchsuchungen gab hier einmal äußerlich wieder in die Christin hat er den Vortrag gehalten zusammen mit,
Kubi Christin hat einen verschlüsselten Nachnamen der wahrscheinlich irgendwie,
40 oder so ausgesprochen wird sie ist Anwältin und Kubi der mit ihr zusammen diesen Vortrag gemacht.
Einer der Betroffenen der Hausdurchsuchungen bei den Zwiebel Freundin klar dass da die Leute irgendwie sogar noch offen.
Boden saßen dann würde ich eigentlich direkt noch die venenerkennung mit dran hängen wenn ich darauf tippen.
Anerkennung Hecken Vortrag von Starbuck und
Julian natürlich irgendwie heiß erwartet warum ist das so spannend es ist deshalb spannend kann ich auch bisher gut erklären welchen schnell ist Nick werden muss dann runter spannend ist das Problem mit biometrischen,
Merkmalen ist ja dass man sie nur,
einmal hat das heißt wenn dein authentisierungs Factor dein Fingerabdruck ist oder dein iris-scan oder dein Gesicht und das verloren geht jemand in der Lage ist das zu klonen
dann hast du ja leider kein zweites Gesicht was du fortan verwenden kannst und.
Primäre Problem mit diesem bisher,
in der Breite verwendeten biometrischen Merkmalen ist dass wir sie eben überall mit uns rumtragen und überall hinterlassen also jeder kann in unsere Augen schauen jeder kann unseren Kopf fotografieren und jedes Glas dass wir anfassen auf dem hinterlassen wir Fingerabdrücke.
Weshalb ist eben seit einiger Zeit schon Systeme gibt die,
die Anordnung der Venen in Hand und oder Fingern als biometrisches Merkmal nutzen,
welches hier den Vorteil hat dass es eben nicht am laufenden Band nach außen getragen wird ja der wird also mit Infrarot durch die Hand geleuchtet und geschaut wie die Anordnung der Venen,
in der Hand ist und das ist bei jedem Menschen ausreichend unterschiedlich sodass ich so sogar eineiige Zwillinge,
anhand dieses Merkmales unterscheiden lassen und das macht natürlich auch stellt gewisse Herausforderung daran dafür eine Attrappe bauen zu können und eben.
Dafür dieses dieses Merkmal zu stehen und da gibt es sehr schöne angriffsvektoren und Beispiele für.
Hör in diesem Vortrag die eben unter anderem
nun Angreifern ist er wirklich ein ich glaube an japanischen Geldautomaten sich zu authentifizieren oder eben auch beim BND der ebenfalls bei der Zugangskontrolle auf solche Scanner setzt vielleicht mal
der kurzen Spaziergang.
Ja dann gabs noch einen schönen netzpolitischer
Einblick von Arne semsrott Rainer Rehak andre Meister und Anna biselli Best of Informationsfreiheit und hier ging es halt natürlich um
die Anwendung des Informationsfreiheitsgesetzes und der
besondere von diesem Personen bereitgestellten Werkzeuge also
Werkzeug natürlich vor allem von Arne semsrott und Team also den difg Anfragen und hier wird wieder sehr unterhaltsamen und
wie viel Einblick berichtet wie erfolgreich das jetzt so war wer den Preis gewonnen hat wie es noch gleich die.
TSG Meisterschaften.
DFG Meisterschaften also darum ging es darum welche ist welches Ministerium antworteten am
schnellsten und das war sehr lustig zu sehen wie die da alle mitgerissen wurden in den Ministerien vor Begeisterung also
schöner Überblick darüber und wer sich immer schon gefragt hat wie man in diese Tools am besten und fand dieses Gesetz gut zum Einsatz bringen kann hier gibt's mal wieder viel
Anregung für die aktive Wahrnehmung von Grund.
Möchte noch einen machen.
Jetzt komme ich leider in die Bereiche wo ich glaube ich nicht alle gesehen habe hier welche logische Studien im Datenmüll den habe ich noch gesehen.
Okay welche das ist mit Katharina nocun und.
Untere t genau der letti welche auch in der Freakshow ja mit,
Team gehört hier unsere visualisierungs Queen und Datenanalyse
Katharina nocun hat mal ganz viel bei Amazon eingekauft mit einem frischen Account und sich da sozusagen so ein Profil gemacht und dann später sich von Amazon die aufgezeichneten Informationen,
Tupperwaren dsgvo Anfrage zukommen zu lassen und dort gibt's dann halt nicht nur eine Liste von gekauften Produkten das wusste man ja schon vorher nein sein.
Cream detaillierte Informationen darüber wie sie sich auf Amazon.com moda.de in dem Fall wahrscheinlich bewegt hatte also bis hin zu jedes einzelne Pixel Wasser angeklickt wurde
und ja gemeinsam,
mit die haben sie dann eben mal ausgewertet was denn eigentlich wirklich in diesem ganzen Daten drin steckt und was man dort herauslesen kann bzw
was Amazon unter Umständen hier vor allem
herauslesen kann welche Korrelation hier denkbar oder eben auch schon naheliegend sind und von daher eine schöne eine schöne Idee für einen Vortrag und dann auch gut aus.
Ein bisschen ich würde sagen fordern da ist auf jeden Fall der Vortrag von Geister ending der den Eröffnungsvortrag gehalten hat.
Über the precariat a disruptiv class for destructive times auf,
Einladung von Frank und mir der ist im.
University Basic Income network relativ aktiv ist ein
Ökonomie Professor also es ist nicht irgendjemand der irgendwie mal daher redet sondern ein finde bin ich immer wieder begeistert sie,
erstens unglaublich gebildet der ist Wasser an an zusammenhängen versteht und andererseits was er für eine
für ein Verständnis eben hat für für für gesellschaftliche Zusammenhänge und wie den wie auch die Ansprache sage ich mal das Wirtschaftssystem für die Menschen ist welche Herausforderungen bereitstehen
und den bin ich also,
sehr sehr begeistert von der hat leider weil er direkt nach dem offenen gesprochen hat den den Saal nicht voll gehabt das wäre aber durchaus ein Tor gewesen der,
das verdient hat.
Wahrscheinlich ne weißt du meinem bisschen minimal zu fordern vielleicht für Leute die nicht einen nicht jeden Tag englische Torx hören andererseits.
Sprich der 6a sehr gut und sehr wie nennt man das denn sehr.
Eloquent.
Eloquent und empathisch und begeisterungsfähig über über das Thema den haben wir nicht ohne.
Grund Andi an dieser Stelle gelegt und es
der behandelt halt nimmt eine metaperspektive wie ich finde auch eines Bereichs der ihm durch die Gesellschaft sehr sehr stark geprägt wird nämlich wie wir in unserer Wirtschaft in Zukunft zusammenleben wollen ich habe das,
auch in den Presseinterview Sun tageins gerne mal gesagt wenn nun durch Digitalisierung und Automatisierung immer mehr Jobs wegfallen.
Dann stellt uns das vor ein Problem,
und für dieses Problem kann es verschiedene Lösungen geben eine wäre eben zu sagen na gut dann haben wir eben viel mehr Arbeitslose aber wir bleiben bei dem Modell dass alle Leute oder ist ein Mensch irgendwie unser Gesellschaft nur dann
wertgeschätzt wird wenn wenn sie in Lohn und Brot steht oder wir überlegen uns was wäre eine sinnvolle,
Neugestaltung des Zusammenlebens beispielsweise mit einem mit einem bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen und was er da benennt mit dem Prekariat.
Was er glaube ich in der ursprünglichen soziologischen Betrachtung immer so ein bisschen auf die die Ungebildeten Tagelöhner,
bezogen wurde also die die prekär Beschäftigten die nicht wissen wann sie ob sie morgen noch Geld verdienen oder so und er vertritt eben das Argument dass ich das sehr stark ausweitet
auf alle gesellschaftlichen Bereiche insbesondere auch in,
in der IT in der alte ist ja Selbstständigkeit eine sehr verbreitete Angelegenheit die eben auch sehr lukrativ sein kann sein kann aber eben auch mit mit ebendieser,
mit dieser Unsicherheit einhergeht ja der Unsicherheit zu wissen
werde ich den übernächsten Monat auch noch gebucht oder kann ich mir also man hat eben diese Planungssicherheit nicht und ich glaube diese Planungssicherheit ist für Menschen.
Sehr wichtiger Zufriedenheit und Sicherheitsfaktor.
Einfach im im Gesamt Zusammenleben und darüber spricht er sehr eloquent sehr emotional und das sollte man auf jeden Fall sich angeschaut.
Ja also ich habe ihn noch nicht ganz zu Ende geschaut ist auf jeden Fall etwas was ein wo man aufmerksam sein sollte beim Zuhören.
Ja es ist erfordert Aufmerksamkeit ist halten sind sind komplexe Zusammenhänge von Imam aufbereitet der sie versteht und der das aber auch finde ich gut versteht sie zu vermitteln.
Ich glaube dann können wir ja so ein bisschen würde ich dir die Runde jetzt abschließen.
Mit der Empfehlung von Leuten die ihr aus dem Logbuch kennt da ist natürlich,
die Schweiz Netzpolitik zwischen Bodensee
und Matterhorn die da eben den sei mal den netzpolitischer Jahresrückblick der Schweiz liefert dann ist da Osterreich zwischen Überwachungsstaat und
oder doch nur Digitalisierung für Anfänger der Vortrag von Thomas Lohninger und,
Angelika Adensamer Twitter handle ist glaube ich abends Sommer deswegen habe ich manchmal Schwierigkeiten mit dem Namen Anna biselli,
ja auch,
oft hier gewesen findet ihr in dem mit dem Vortrag Computer die über Asyl mit entscheiden und natürlich unter dem gerade schon von Tim empfohlenen Informationsfreiheit Highlights.
Und andre Meister hat dann auch noch mal über Funkzellenabfrage einen Vortrag zusammen mit Ulf.
Burmeier gehalten und ich glaube.
Wenn wir jetzt noch kurz Cord in die act and erwähnen den zweiten Vortrag von Anne,
semsrott das ist tatsächlich ein Problem also das habe ich glaube ich auch schon öfter erzählt Anne wollen wir eigentlich jedes Jahr nicht im Programm haben.
Weil er im Jahr davor war und wir sagen jetzt muss auch mal irgendwann gut sein
aber wenn er dann irgendwie mal kurz nebenbei noch aus dem Hütchen schuld schüttelt das offene gesetze-im-internet jetzt wirklich offene Gesetze im Internet sind.
Und wenn er im was was ich mit die renommiertesten investigativ Journalisten des Landes irgendwie mit seinem mit seinem mit seinem frag den Staat
auf die Bühne kriegt dann kann man ihn eben irgendwann diese Torx nicht mehr verwehren das ist sehr ärgerlich.
So ist das mit diesem populären Vortragenden.
Und ich glaube dann hätten wir jetzt wahrscheinlich wenn ich mich nicht
täusche zumindest die Logbuch Netzpolitik Verwandten.
Torx mal abgehandelt und bevor das jetzt einfach nur in so eine so ein langes runterbeten von Cocktail.
Geht würde ich sagen lasse euch jetzt erstmal mit diesen Empfehlungen allein die könnt ihr dann nämlich bis nächste Woche bis zum nächsten Logbuch gehört haben und dann gibt's weiterhin betreutes media.ccc und chill.
Genau überlegen wir dann noch ein bisschen nach und gibt uns die Gelegenheit selber auch immer sonntags anzuschauen,
aber natürlich mal wieder nicht so viel möglich auf der Veranstaltung naja.
Vielleicht eine kurze Sache noch Zahlung und schöne Dinge bei Chaos West gab's dann so ein Vorfall da wir sind wohl ein paar Rechner abhandengekommen.
Das ist natürlich etwas was wir überhaupt nicht gut finden und das ist auch nicht
typisch für diese Veranstaltung ist nur wenn man dazu sagen normalerweise drückt sich der Kongress durch ein hohes Sicherheitsgefühl aus weil einfach dort viel Vertrauen ist und generell
auch viel gegenseitig auf dich aufgepasst wird,
bei 17000 Leuten bleibt wohl nicht aus dass wir dann auch passende schwarze Schafe auf der Veranstaltung haben
vielleicht noch nicht mal zu treffen ist insofern als dass es sich hier auch
kann ich mal um ein Schaf gehandelt haben muss was hier irgendwie zur Erde gehört sondern sich hier andere Leute vielleicht verdient haben auf jeden Fall sind das Laptops abhandengekommen das für mir nicht gut und deswegen unterstützen wir auch.
Einen Spendenaufruf um dort den Schaden zumindest finanziell erträglich.
Ja das ist das gilt es zu tadeln wer auch immer da die Rechner mitgenommen hat hat jetzt noch Gelegenheit die zurück zu.
Genau allerdings näher.
Ja noch könnte man das unter habe ich gefunden fairbuch.
Sehr großzügig bereit das jetzt noch unter einer im Weihnachtsstress verzögerten Rückgabe des Geräts.
Als ehrbar zu werden.
Ja alina ist das bringt uns ans Ende der Sendung die war jetzt ein bisschen länger das war nicht überraschend.
Ja ist doch schön dann sind wir jetzt durch mit der Sendung für heute.
Monteur entlassen euch.
Der kommt bestimmt.
Genau jetzt lasst euch ins neue Jahr
bunte shot schön viel Kongress Torx und dürft uns auch gerne auf Dinge hinweisen und generell Feedback geben Kommentare schreiben und so weiter wisst Bescheid vielen Dank fürs Zuhören diesmal und wir sagen tschüss.
Genau und vergess nicht an eine schöne Netz politisch aktive Organisation eurer Wahl zu spenden.
Ciao ciao.